So Leute, ich bin auch zur Abwechslung mal da, Dienstagabend, Boomer müde, es ist schon spät, Boomer müde, so schlimm ist es noch nicht, aber fast 20 Uhr ist nicht mal lange hin, moin, ich muss mal ein bisschen ordentliche Musik anmachen, dass ich wach werde wieder, eine Runde Headbang,
ich mach gleich ein bisschen was Hintergrund-gedudelt-tauglicheres an, moin, hat jemand von euch schon die Abschlussprüfungsnoten, gibt's da schon was, ich vermute mal noch nicht, denke nicht, sowas dauert ja immer 1-2 Monate gefühlt, oder 5-6 Wochen, moin,
Kai Nummer 2, ne, Kai 2-1, irgendwie hab ich Kai Nummer 2 gelesen auf den ersten Blick, frag nicht warum, Chillfreak auch am Start, Pogu, ja, Leute, so sieht's aus, dieser gemischte Musikgespräch aus Videospielmusik und Metal ist unter Informatik echt verbreitet, warum, ist das, warum auch nicht, ist doch eine gute Sache, ich mag sowohl, mach ich mal aus, komm ich mach mal ein bisschen was Hintergrund-verträglicheres an,
ist übrigens auch Game-Musik, wo wir gerade...
dabei sind, auch wenn sich's vielleicht nicht so angehört hat, das ist auch ein Game-Soundtrack, deswegen kann ich den hier im Stream auch spielen, ansonsten, tja, ne, wieder nicht, aber ich geb zu, es ist, es ist schon ziemlicher Kontrast, ziemliches Kontrastprogramm von dem hier, sagen wir mal zu dem hier, aber ich mag beides, generell muss ich sagen, ähm, also, es gibt jetzt schon durchaus Musikgenres, die mir gar nicht zusagen, ja,
also, aber, wenn das, wenn das Zeug gut gemacht ist und ich irgendwie da so ein bisschen so, so Melodie-mäßig was raushöre, was mir gefällt, ich, äh, hör mir auch durchaus anderes Zeug an als Game-Musik und Metal, aber, gefällt mir eigentlich in der Regel am besten, ja, ich hab, äh, so für Hintergrund-Sachen, das Game-Soundtracks und sowas, und auch zum Konzentrieren sind Gaming-Soundtracks mega nice, und ansonsten muss auch mal ein bisschen Head, Head, Headbanged werden, das waren wir heute, Leute, ich kann nix machen großartig heute, ich bin übelst im Arsch,
will der Igel eins, moin, ich kann nix machen, es gibt doch 8-Bit-Heavy-Metal, ja, klar, übrigens, habt ihr gesehen, jetzt, wo ich den Ragman hier sehe, Leute, es gibt, lass mich mal kurz irgendeine andere, irgendeine, jawoll, excellent, pock, äh, ich weiß nicht, ob ihr es gesehen habt, aber so anstrengend, nee, das ist es nicht, also, es, es, es ist schon ein bisschen anstrengend,
weil man sich halt konzentrieren muss, weil man ein bisschen neues Zeug lernen muss, nee, aber, also, es sind, es sind mehrere, es sind, es sind mehrere Sachen, erstens neue Arbeit, zweitens bin ich normalerweise abends um die Uhrzeit gar nicht on, und das zweite ist, äh, ich hab ein bisschen, mit, ein bisschen Zahnweh, wobei nicht wirklich Zahnweh, sondern eher Zahnfleisch oben, das ist halt genau da, wo ich seit Jahren schon Probleme hab,
mein Zahnarzt meint auch, ja, also, ihm fällt da, ihm fällt da langsam nix mehr ein.
Ja, das ist halt, das ist halt kacke, weil, ich hab, oben links hatte ich, hatte ich ganz lange noch einen Weisheitszahn, ich erzähl euch das jetzt einfach mal, ja, oben links hatte ich ganz lange noch Weisheitszähne drin, die hab ich erst vor ein paar Jahren, naja, paar Jahre ist schon gut her, sagen wir mal, boah, jetzt über zehn Jahre oder so, äh, raus, rausbekommen, oder, ich glaub, ich hab sogar zwölf Jahre oder so, ist auf jeden Fall, aber ich hatte die relativ lang,
und
als der Weisheitszahn oben links raus war, hat man halt festgestellt, dass der
Zahn,
der Zahn davor ziemlich in Mitleidenschaft gezogen ist, schon, halt an Stellen, wo man halt nichts gesehen hat vorher, weil der Weisheitszahn davor war, und seitdem hatte ich da oben halt, äh, so den halben Zahn gefühlt als Füllung drinne, bis das irgendwann angefangen hat wehzutun, da hab ich ne Wurzelbehandlung gemacht gekriegt, oben, bis das auch wieder angefangen hat wehzutun, und jetzt weiß mein Zahnarzt nicht mehr so genau, was er machen soll, ich mein, man könnte jetzt nochmal das Ganze nochmal, nochmal aufmachen und nochmal, ähm, nochmal neu auffüllen,
und sowas, nochmal alles reinigen, und sowas, aber das, das sackt halt, ne, es schwankt halt, mal tut's bisschen weh, mal nicht, es ist halt nervig, wobei, witzigerweise, nachts tut mir der Zahn nicht weh, tagsüber schon, normalerweise ist es umgedreht, tagsüber merkt man's nicht so nachts dafür richtig, ja, keine Ahnung, Zahnarztbein, das könnte auch Zahnfleisch sein, weil das wohl ein bisschen entzündet aussieht, aber, weiß ich, so lange jetzt, ach, keine Ahnung, ja, aber ich wollte euch noch was anderes zeigen, also, ich hab nächste, also, ich war letzte Woche schon beim Zahnarzt, ich hab nächste Woche, geht's, ich hab nächste Woche, geht's, ich hab nächste Woche, geht's, ich hab nächste Woche, geht's, ich hab nächste Woche, geht's, ich hab nächste Woche, geht's, ich hab nächste Woche
ich geh nochmal zum Zahnarzt, und ohne Scheiß, weil ich sag euch, äh, ich hab da langsam keinen Bock mehr drauf, wenn das bis nächste Woche Montag nicht weg ist, äh, frag ich den Zahnarzt, was man da am besten machen kann, und, selbst wenn er sagt, Zahn weg, und Prothese rein, oder wie man das nennt, wie nennt man das bei Zähnen eigentlich, lass ich das machen, juck mich nicht, selbst wenn's 2000 Euro kostet, ist mir egal, Hauptsache ich hab nicht, äh, Hauptsache ich hab nicht mehr alle, alle Furzlangen oben links, äh, Implantat heißt das, ja,
du meinst zum Geld sparen, naja, so arm bin ich nicht, das kann ich mir ja schon leisten, äh, ordentliche, ordentliche Behandlung, also ich geh nicht davon aus, dass er sagt, Zahn raus, sondern ich geh davon aus, dass er sagt, hier, können wir nochmal, müssen wir nochmal auffüllen, nochmal gucken, ob irgendwie Wurzelspitze, irgendwas, keine Ahnung, eigentlich hab ich keinen Bock drauf, ey, mir wär's fast lieber, da mach den Zahn raus und ein Implantat rein, und dann ist endgültig Ruhe, man, und der Kram funktioniert doch auch wunderbar,
also es gibt so ein paar Sachen, dafür lohnt sich's Geld auszugeben, das sind unter anderem,
gescheiten Zahnersatz, und generell so, Gesundheits- und Krankheitssachen, dafür lohnt sich's einfach Geld auszugeben, weil du hast nix davon, ein paar Euro zu sparen und scheiße behandelt zu werden, also Behandlung in Form von ärztlicher Behandlung, ja, andere Behandlung auch, aber es, das lohnt sich da teilweise einfach mal ein bisschen Geld auszugeben, was, das Auto ist kaputt gegangen, oh, das ist aber schlecht, also mein, beim Fiat geht's noch gut, haben wir hierüber schon gesprochen, nee,
Field will return in an entirely new, die labern alle immer rum, wenn Andrew Wilson das sagt, dann kann das ja nur gut werden, der ist ja nicht irgendwie damit verantwortlich, dass es überhaupt so geworden ist,
also, ob noch mehr EA-Steuerung da was bringt, gut, ey, der Fehler von 2042 liegt sicherlich nicht nur an EA, aber das hat garantiert auch einen großen Anteil dran gehabt,
aber das ist ja aktuell ziemlich nicht so,
das ist so, wir haben halt mal was gesagt und jetzt ist gut, also das ist halt, das ist halt echt viel Bullshit-Gelaber wieder, keine Ahnung, dann fällt ja anscheinend sonst nix ein,
Battlefield 2042 wird wahrscheinlich nie in einem guten Zustand kommen, wobei das Spiel ja mittlerweile tatsächlich so weit ist, dass man sagen könnte, ja, okay, demnächst könnten wir es vielleicht releasen,
es fühlt sich immer noch nicht richtig wie ein gutes Battlefield an, aber ich meine, es ist immerhin jetzt,
so weit bugfrei und zumindest halbwegs umfangreich, dass man es mal ein bisschen spielen kann, aber das Spiel ist halt seit zwei Jahren oder so raus, richtig, richtig Hyper-Fail.
Übrigens, ich wollte euch was zeigen, guckt mal hier, Leute, ich muss mich heute mal ein bisschen entspannen, muss mal ein bisschen weniger aufgebracht reden hier, oder was ist aufgebracht, bin ich aufgebracht, aber ein bisschen weniger,
Engaged reden mit euch, muss man ein bisschen, ein bisschen ausruhen, also, es gibt neue Hintergründe und zwar, der Rackman hat einen neuen Hintergrund gebaut, nämlich einen Pepo White Happy mit,
teilt euch fest, mit Energy Drink, mit einem Booster, so war das nicht gedacht, okay, so funktioniert es anscheinend, was auch immer,
echt, ach, du wolltest,
den haben, der ist für mich ja in 50 Billiarden gewesen, ach so, wusste ich gar nicht, warum lädt er sich das runter, ist, ist GitHub irgendwie total bescheuert, für dich ist das, alles, kleine Auftragsarbeit, ja, dürfen wir das überhaupt auf GitHub benutzen, wenn das Fiverr Auftragsarbeit von dir ist, ja, zumindest, das ist neu, das Image,
das heißt, wir haben jetzt noch,
eins mehr für,
Tag, wir haben den Burger und den Drink, wir haben den Keks, der Keks, äh, der Pepo am Arbeiten, der K-Pepo mit dem Booster Drink,
und die Vorlage für alle, die irgendwelche anderen Images machen wollen,
das ist,
exzellent,
ich muss das übrigens hier gerade mal pullen, fällt mir auf,
weil,
hier habe ich es noch gar nicht,
ja,
sehr schön,
jetzt gibt es auch den neuen Hintergrund hier,
mal was, mal, mal, was komplett, äh,
side getracktes,
ja, habt ihr, habt ihr mitbekommen, dass Google heute eine ziemlich blöde Idee hatte,
äh, was heißt heute,
die, die letzten Monate über schon, einige doofe Ideen, aber,
mal wieder, mal wieder eine ziemlich blöde Idee, und zwar,
ähm,
ja,
und zwar Google,
hat gesagt, es gibt jetzt die Top-Level-Domain,
Punkt,
Zip,
also, ne, zum Beispiel hier, maxfps.zip, und so was, also Zip ist eine neue Top-Level-Domain,
und, äh,
das ist da,
missbräuchliche Benutzung zu dieser Domain geben könnte,
ist, glaube ich, jedem, wenn er diese Änderung sich anguckt, schon instant klar,
aber Google hat sich gedacht, nein, es ist trotzdem ne super Idee, diese Domain der Öffentlichkeit
zugänglich zu machen,
und wisst ihr was, eines der ersten, ich mach die Seite jetzt nicht, nicht auf, ja, ich,
ich weiß nicht, was es da zu sehen gibt, zurzeit, wenn man drauf geht, und ich will
euch da auch nicht irgendwie dazu verleiten, da drauf zu gehen,
eine der ersten Domains, die registriert wurden, unter dieser neuen Top-Level-Domain, Punkt, Zip, war,
haltet euch fest,
Microsoft Office, Punkt, Zip,
Whois,
wie, Whois hab ich nicht installiert,
Microsoft Office, Punkt, Zip,
diese Domain kann ja nur
komplett legale, 100% legit, legit Absichten haben, wer sich so ne Domain registriert, oder?
So, und der Skem ging natürlich sofort los, guckt's euch an, Microsoft Office, Punkt, Zip,
gefakter Microsoft Login, um Accountdaten abzugreifen, also was für eine bescheuerte Idee von Google
überhaupt, so eine Top-Level-Domain zu machen, ich mein, was ist denn als nächstes, Top-Level-Domain,
Punkt, Exe, oder was, was, Punkt, Butt, oder so, was, was fällt ihnen denn als nächstes
noch ein?
Also .zip ist wirklich eine mega bescheuerte Idee gewesen, das als Top-Level-Domain irgendwie zu vermarkten.
Wie war das eigentlich damals, als es noch .com-Dateien gab?
Ich glaube, damals gab es, also die Probleme gab es da theoretisch schon, aber ich glaube, das hat damals nicht so viel ausgenutzt.
Zumal ja auch .com-Dateien äußerst selten verschickt werden.
Und .zip-Dateien relativ häufig.
Weil nur rein, weil es die Dateiendung gibt, ist ja nicht problematisch.
Problematisch ist ja zum Beispiel, weil du jetzt faken kannst, so nach dem Motto, ich schicke dir jetzt Microsoft Office .zip.
Und in Wirklichkeit ist es eigentlich ein Link auf eine Domain und wir versuchen deine Account-Credentials abzukramen.
.download gibt es auch nicht.
Ja, aber das ist ja auch egal.
Also das Problem bei .zip ist ja nur, dass du Dateinamen faken kannst.
Microsoft Office...
Microsoft Office .zip zum Beispiel.
Und als Link sieht das aus, für Unwissende, so nach dem Motto, es könnte eine Datei sein, die angehängt war, aber in Wirklichkeit ist es halt hier so eine Fake-Microsoft-Seite.
Also, aus meiner Sicht, echt dumme Idee von Google, das hier alles...
Oh, was ist mit der Playlist los, Mann?
Also aus meiner Sicht, absolut bescheuerte Idee von Google .zip als Top-Level-Domain hier rauszubringen oder zu ermöglichen.
Bestimmt.
Bestimmt, Bice.
Und wahrscheinlich gibt es auch Porn.zip und solche Sachen.
Bitcoin.zip, genau solche Dinger.
Leute, das ist jetzt halt das Problem, dass sowas hier im Chat jetzt eine klickbare, wirklich existierende Domain sein kann.
Das ist halt...
Also ich finde es bescheuert, dass es die Domain gibt.
Also, mich würde nicht wundern, wenn Browser...
7.zip gibt es tatsächlich.
Ja, 7.zip.
Ja.
Ist wohl auch das Offizielle.
Also, mich würde nicht wundern, wenn zumindest Firefox im nächsten Release alle diese Domains blockt.
Und ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass ich Google anschließen muss, diese Domains zu blocken.
Ja, ganz sicher echte Rechnung .zip.
Also, richtig dumme Idee.
Um es mal so zu sagen.
Es sind ja nicht eigene Domains.
Das sind ja keine Google Domains.
Also, du kannst dir die auch registrieren.
Wie wichtig sind deiner Meinung nach Schulungen von Produkten?
Oder ist zum Beispiel bei ESX mit Google und Basiswissen andere Mitarbeiterfirma alles möglich?
Hä?
Was?
Moment, das verstehe ich jetzt nicht.
Moment, das muss ich nochmal...
Wie wichtig sind deiner Meinung nach externe Schulungen von Produkten?
Oder ist zum Beispiel bei ESX mit Google und Basiswissen...
Achso!
Achso, wie wichtig das ist.
Meinst du jetzt für dich, um einen Job zu finden?
Oder...
Oder in deiner Firma, um Leute mit Know-How auszustatten?
Also, es gibt sicherlich Produkte, da ist das überhaupt kein Ding.
Da kommst du mit Google, Basiswissen und Tutorials lesen durch.
Mit VMware wahrscheinlich auch.
Allerdings hat VMware sehr viele Feinheiten und sehr viele, ja vielleicht nicht so ganz offensichtliche Dinger.
Ich bin kein VMware-Admin.
Ich kann dir da nicht allzu viel dazu sagen.
Aber ich kenne ein paar.
Und ich würde sagen, das ist ein sehr komplexes Feld.
Wo es wahrscheinlich nicht...
verkehrt ist, sich die ein oder andere Schulung mal zu besorgen.
Wenn es jetzt einfach nur ums Ausprobieren geht, sodass du ein bisschen Kenntnisse in deinen Lebenslauf schreiben kannst,
beziehungsweise in deine Skill-Liste, ja, dann reicht natürlich Googeln und Ausprobieren aus.
Aber wenn es um Enterprise-Einsatz geht und dann dort auch Feinheiten beachtet werden sollen,
dann ist es sicherlich nicht verkehrt, mal ein bisschen Input zu bekommen von Leuten, die richtig Ahnung von VMware haben.
Muss ich halt nur überlegen, ob man sich jetzt...
also was man sich für Unternehmen, für die Schulung holt, weil da ist auch viel Müll dabei.
Ich mache mal kurz meine VM an und mache mal ein Update.
Wir hatten mal wieder Zeit.
Arch, by the way, musst du ja immer updaten.
Deswegen kann ich das gerade mal machen, dass ich beim nächsten Stream, wo wir wirklich die VM brauchen, nicht wieder erst mal 10 Minuten updaten muss.
Ja.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das eine Frage ist.
Soweit beantwortet hat.
Aber wenn du was Konkreteres wissen willst, musst du mich konkret erfragen.
Mehr fällt mir da gerade nicht zu ein.
Also, wie gesagt, ich finde es eine richtig blöde Idee, dass es .zip als Domain jetzt gibt.
Total, total hängen geblieben.
Ja, man sieht ja hier schon die...
Das sind alles jetzt gültige Domains, also potenziell gültige Domains,
die alle für irgendwelche Scamscheiß benutzt werden können.
Was erzählt da der Nightbot jetzt?
Warum spammt er so oft hintereinander?
Was ist mit dem los?
Anzeige ist raus.
Übrigens, Leute, mal was ganz anderes.
Ich habe heute Morgen auf meinem Handy das Most Kokona aller Zeiten Video empfohlen bekommen.
Also, ich fand das...
Es ist kein lustiges Video, ja?
Ich fand das aber so...
Die Situation so lustig, weil das so eine typische Kokona-Ami-Situation ist,
die nirgendwo auf der Welt wahrscheinlich so laufen würde wie bei den Amis.
Ich muss bloß gerade mal in meine...
Ich muss bloß gerade...
Ich muss bloß gerade mal kurz in meine Watch-History gucken,
ob ich das...
ob ich das finde.
Das ist so ein...
ein Home-Defense-Video.
Ihr könnt euch schon vorstellen, was abgeht bei den Amis,
wenn es ums Thema Home-Defense geht.
Wir müssen uns so die ersten 30 Sekunden angucken.
Da musst du...
Die ersten 30 Sekunden sind so typisch Kokona-Ami-Blödsinn.
Okay.
Home-Defense?
Und wie heißt das?
Home-Defense...
Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Ähm...
Was Nachgestelltes.
Fall victim to this invasion.
Irgendwie sowas heißt das Video.
Genau.
So, passt mal auf.
Der Typ sieht halt auch schon mal aus wie...
wie irgend so ein Ex-Special-Forces-Dude, ja?
Guck mal.
Typischer...
Typischer Tag.
Also haltet euch fest.
Typischer Tag eines Hausbewohners in den USA.
Typisch...
Typischer Tag, ja?
Die Amis, Alter!
Die Amis, Mann!
Hallo?
Das Erste, was du machst, ist, wenn irgendein Typ vor deiner Tür auftaucht,
erst mal abknallen, ja?
Die Amis, Alter!
Die...
Die Amis...
Die sind aber...
Die sind wirklich nicht mal ganz dicht.
Ich meine, okay.
Ich gebe zu.
Hey.
Ich würde...
Ich würde auch erst mal blöd gucken, wenn so ein Dude auf mich zugreifen kann.
Aber wisst ihr, was ich machen würde?
Ich würde die Tür zumachen, anstatt den zu erschießen.
Ich würde wahrscheinlich einfach die Tür zuhauen.
Das ist so ein typisch Ami-Ding.
Du machst die Tür auf.
Es läuft vor der Tür dir einer entgegen.
Erst mal...
Erst mal Waffe.
Rausholen.
Ja.
Hey.
Moment.
Der Typ ist bewaffnet, weil es so eine typische Ami-Geschichte ist, ja?
Bei uns wird...
Stell dir mal vor, bei uns.
Du machst die Tür auf.
Da läuft irgendein Typ dann vor der Tür rum, rennt rum aufs Erste und bam, erst mal abschießt.
Das ist so eine typische Ami-Situation, ja?
Das ist so eine typische Ami-Situation.
Die gibt es wahrscheinlich nirgendwo sonst auf der Welt.
Immer mit geladener Waffe die Tür aufmachen, ja?
Also...
Der muss da halt sein Property defenden.
Und ich mein, hey, es gibt auch welche, die stehen da gleich mit der Shotgun oder so rum.
Das war wirklich so ein typischer Ami-Moment.
Ich weiß übrigens auch nicht, warum mir dieses Video hier...
Warum mir das empfohlen wurde.
Aber...
Aus irgendwelchen Gründen war YouTube der Meinung, ich will...
Ähm...
Home-Defense.
Home-Defense-Technik in Amis.
Äh, im Ami-Land lernen.
Aber...
Das ist wirklich eines der kokonigsten Videos, die ich je gesehen habe.
Ah, guck mal, ich mach die Tür auf.
Ah, da läuft einer.
Bam, erst mal erschießen.
Leiste Taktik.
Ähm...
Jetzt ist die große Preisfrage...
Ah, hier hatte ich das Video auf.
Das ist jetzt aber sehr verwirrend.
Weil eigentlich habe ich hier die Videos auf und die Musik habe ich hier auf.
Das heißt, wenn ich das jetzt mische, dann blicke ich gar nicht mehr durch.
Vielleicht ist das Home-Defense-Home-Automation.
Das kann sein.
Also keine Ahnung, warum mir Google das heute Morgen empfohlen hat.
Sowas zum Beispiel.
Das sieht auch sehr Kokona-mäßig aus.
Aber das hat mich schon heute Morgen wieder verwirrt.
Ja, das erste, was die Amis machen, ist erst mal mit der Pistole an die Tür.
Und sobald sich einer bewegt, wird erst mal abgeknallt.
Das Blöde bei denen ist halt, dass du damit rechnen musst, dass der Typ, der da auf deinem...
Rasen rumrennt, auch irgendeine Pistole dabei hat.
Das ist ja also eines der Hauptargumente, die die haben.
Dort für...
Für Pistolen.
Also die sehen das da halt alles ein bisschen anders als wir.
Ich glaube, da kann man sich auch hier relativ schlecht reinversetzen.
Für die ist halt Waffen besitzen, Waffen haben, Waffen benutzen dürfen und ist halt Teil von...
Von Freedom.
Das können wir, glaube ich, relativ schnell...
Also relativ schlecht nachvollziehen.
Aber das Dumme ist halt auch, dass du in jeder Situation dann rechnen musst...
Damit rechnen musst, dass die andere Seite halt auch gerade seinen...
Freedom wahrnimmt.
Ja, das ist schon merkwürdig.
Ja, das kann...
Ja, ich glaube, das können wir schlecht nachvollziehen.
Ja, und also eines der Hauptargumente, die ich immer von Amis höre und ich kann das aus ihrer Sicht durchaus nachvollziehen, ist...
Ich brauche eine Pistole, weil...
Was mache ich, wenn mich einer überfällt mit einer Pistole?
So, und mit dem Argument kriegst du bei den Amis eigentlich immer so die...
Die Kurve und sagst, ja, okay, dann brauche ich eine Pistole.
Am besten wäre natürlich, wenn gar keiner standardmäßig eine Pistole dabei hat.
Ja, richtig, genau.
Genau das meine ich, ja.
Ja, ja, ja, genau.
Es ist...
Ich glaube, da ist auch schwierig, was so als Außenstehender dagegen zu sagen.
Ich glaube, wir können das gar nicht richtig nachvollziehen.
Genau.
Das ist...
Das ist das...
Das ist die Ami-Logik.
Wenn du überfallen wirst von einem mit einer Pistole, ist das Beste, wenn du selbst eine Pistole dabei hast.
Was ja nicht unbedingt einer gewissen...
Wie soll ich sagen?
So einer gewissen Logik entbehrt.
Was aber halt auch irgendwo zu so einer Art Wettrüsten sorgt, ja.
So nach dem Motto, ich gehe gar nicht mehr ohne Pistole raus.
Nein, nein, du hast was vergessen.
Sicherheit ist egal.
Freedom.
Muss es sein.
Hell yeah, freedom.
Und natürlich, und natürlich alles andere auch.
Aber sollen sie machen.
Ich meine, das ist halt ihr Ding.
Das ist halt, das ist halt so das Ami-Ding.
Das kann ich mir vorstellen.
Überlege gerade, gab es noch irgendwas Spannendes heute, news-technisch?
Ich glaube nicht.
Jetzt bei euch noch irgendwas Spannendes.
Vermutlich nicht so Dienstag.
Dienstag ist immer so ein langweiliger Tag, gell.
Da ist eigentlich so gut wie nie was.
Und das Gute ist, nicht vergessen, Leute.
Donnerstag ist Feiertag.
Ja.
Ich meine, wenn du an Schulen schon irgendwelche Metalldetektoren brauchst.
Vodafone entlässt paar tausend Leute.
Das habe ich gelesen.
Vodafone entlässt aber wohl...
In Deutschland, ich kriege es im Kopf nicht mehr.
Ich glaube, die entlassen irgendwie tausend, dreihundert Leute.
Stellen aber vierhundert neue Leute ein.
Und die entlassen hauptsächlich Leute im mittleren Management, Verwaltung und solche Geschichten.
Und was Support und Technik angeht, scheinen die wohl neue Leute einzustellen.
Also insofern eigentlich eine begrüßenswerte Entscheidung, weniger Bullshit-Schwätzer und mehr Technik-Leute einzustellen.
Was ja für einen Internet-Provider, der wohl auch Probleme mit seinem Service und Problemen hat,
keine allzu schlechte Entscheidung ist.
Wir können mal kurz gucken, ob ich...
Heise hat da irgendeinen Artikel dazu.
Unsere Leistungen waren nicht gut genug.
Jawoll.
Sagen sie.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wo es steht, wie viele Leute.
Hier, hier, genau.
Tausend, dreihundert Jobs.
So, Moment.
Ja.
Also, genau.
Die schmeißen tausend, dreihundert Leute raus und stellen vierhundert neue ein.
Und sie stellen hauptsächlich Leute, die sich in der Technik befinden.
Und sie stellen hauptsächlich neue Leute ein im Bereich auf Service und Technik.
Also, finde ich durchaus nachvollziehbar, dass man sagt, bisschen weniger Gemiete,
bisschen weniger Management-Hierarchien, bisschen weniger Blödsinn-Gelaber,
sondern bisschen mehr Service und Technik.
Was durchaus nach einem Plan klingt für einen Provider, der es sonst nicht auf die Reihe kriegt.
Moin, Emco.
Ja, ich muss sagen, ich bin nicht, also ich bin bei Vodafone.
Wirklich zufrieden mit dem Laden war ich noch nie.
Ich bin nur bei Vodafone, also der einzige Grund, warum ich bei Vodafone bin, ist in Ermangelung einer sinnvollen Alternative.
Ich hatte am Anfang, als ich hier eingezogen bin, 2013, hatte ich noch DSL von der Telekom.
Leider hat es die Telekom auch mit VDSL-Ausbau und sowas erst hier relativ spät hinbekommen.
Und VDSL selbst war halt auch nie schneller hier, glaube ich, als...
Was ist das schnellste von VDSL? 100 oder 250?
Eis fliegt, danke schön für den Sub.
Also, mehr kam da halt nie.
Mehr kam da halt nie.
Und dementsprechend blieb mir nichts anderes übrig, als zu Vodafone zu gehen.
Gerade auch, was die Upload... Wobei, die Upload-Geschwindigkeit war bei VDSL, glaube ich, okay.
Aber die Kombination aus...
Download-Upload-Geschwindigkeit.
Also, mir blieb eigentlich nichts, was Speed angeht, gar nicht wirklich viel übrig.
Außer zu Vodafone zu gehen und halt bei denen Fernseh und Internet zu nehmen.
Wobei, Fernseh ist jetzt nicht das, wo ich sagen würde, ah, dafür brauche ich unbedingt eine extra Leitung.
Das wird es bei mir auch über irgendeinen Streaming-Dienst tun.
Also, wie gesagt, ich war noch nie wirklich zufrieden mit Vodafone und davor mit Unity Media auch nicht.
Und seit es Vodafone ist, vielleicht sogar noch einen Ticken weniger.
Ja, Unity Media war auch Hyper-Crap.
Kann man nicht anders sagen, gell.
So.
Ja.
Also, die Entscheidung, wie gesagt, 1300 Management und sonstige Dinger abzubauen...
...und Service und Technik aufzubauen, finde ich durchaus nachvollziehbar und wahrscheinlich auch die richtige...
...die richtige Richtung.
Mein eigenes Glasfaser ins Haus legen.
Ich wäre der Erste.
Ich bin sofort dabei, sobald die bei uns die Straße aufmachen.
Ich bring denen noch Kaffee vorbei.
Die das legen.
Also, sobald es hier losgeht, bin ich der Erste, der sich das einstöpseln lässt.
Gatschibass.
Ich lasse es mir direkt reinfahren, das Glasfaser.
Aber gibt es hier noch nicht.
Insofern ein bisschen verständlich.
Also, hier gerade Hanau und Umgebung wird sehr viel ausgebaut aktuell.
Die haben sich auch letztens irgendwie gefeiert, dass sie die Glasfaser-Ziele...
...übertroffen haben und sowas in der Richtung.
Ja gut, wo nichts ist, kannst du dich relativ easy übertreffen.
Aber nachdem es bei mir in meinem Gebiet ja schon ganz gute Versorgung gibt...
...mit VDSL und Vodafone bis Gigabit über Kabel...
...sind wir, glaube ich, nicht erste Priorität beim Ausbau, sondern eher ein bisschen drum herum.
Was aber auch okay ist.
Was finde ich auch erstmal in Ordnung ist.
Aber über kurz oder lang wird es das ja auch geben.
Ja.
Also, da bin ich mir relativ sicher, das wird nicht mehr lange dauern.
Dann kommen die hier auch angerückt und...
...Glasfaser.
Was ich lustig fand, die letzten sind im Nachbarort hier.
Ich glaube es war...
...in...
...Langensellbold war das, glaube ich.
Genau.
Also, die ganze Weltstätte hier mal in der Nähe erwähnt.
In Langensellbold bin ich letztens durchgelaufen und festgestellt...
...ach, guck mal da, da wird überall Glas...
...so kleines, kleines...
...Dorf kann man nicht sagen, aber...
...ziemlich kleine Stadt ist das.
Und...
...da bin ich letztens durchgelaufen.
Die haben da schöne Weinberge, wo man wandern kann und sowas.
Bin ich durchgelaufen und habe gesehen, guck mal da...
...die machen hier überall die Straße auf, legen Glasfaser...
...und überall standen auch so...
...so Pappaufstelldinger, so Plakate und Sachen rum.
So nach dem Motto, hier Glasfaser und hier anmelden und sowas.
Denke ich mir, cool, bei denen geht es zur Sache.
Und dann gucke ich zwei Tage später in die News...
...und lese irgendwas von...
...ich weiß gar nicht mehr, ob es Wasser ein...
...Stromaus...
...Stromausfall war es, glaube ich, Stromausfall.
Da hat irgendein Bagger beim Glasfaser verlegen...
...oder beim Straßeaufbauen irgendein Bagger...
...hat einfach noch ein bisschen mehr durch...
...Gaslag war es, Gaslag, glaube ich.
Das kann gewesen sein, ja.
Hat irgendein Bagger ein bisschen zu viel...
...gebaggert.
Aber hey, wie ist das, wie sagt man so schön...
...wo gehobelt wird, fallen Späne.
Übrigens, heute war in Hanau...
...bundesweite, nee, wie heißt das...
...Warn-App-Warnung in Hanau...
...Warnung in Hanau...
...Hanau...
...Warnung-Bund...
...gar nicht so weit weg von mir...
...gab es heute eine...
...eine Warnung, nämlich...
...äh, wo ist das hin?
Hä?
Also heute Morgen gab...
...warum steht denn das da nicht mehr drin?
Heute Morgen, es sind nur aktuelle Warnungen.
Okay, kann man vielleicht auch sowas...
...wie Hanau hinzufügen?
Ja.
Keine History oder sowas.
Also heute Morgen gab es nämlich hier...
...in Hanau eine Warnung...
...dass...
...irgendwo hier oben...
...gab es irgendeinen Großbrand und man sollte...
...wegen giftiger Gase und so...
...Fenster und alles geschlossen halten.
Da habe ich mir schon gedacht, MonkaS, Alter, dass mal bei uns in der Ecke was passiert.
Nö.
Ich habe zumindest nichts gekriegt.
Also es sind selten Warnungen...
...bei mir hier in der Ecke...
...so mit Fenster geschlossen halten...
...oder sowas.
Also habe ich bis jetzt noch nicht gesehen.
Und was witzig ist, über...
...die Hessen-Warn-App kam nichts.
Über die Bundes-Warn-App...
...beziehungsweise Seite kam was.
Also sehr weird...
...Champ.
Was das dumme bei mir ist, es gibt jetzt 50 Mbit, da ist...
...mehr oder weniger alles...
Hä? Ne, die bauen trotzdem aus, auch mit 50 Mbit, oder?
Das ist doch unter anderem...
...eines dieser Sachen, die sie in ihrer komischen...
... äh...
...Glasfaser-Roadmap da beschlossen haben.
Bei uns im Ort...
...wollen die Glasfaser ausbauen, wenn 50...
...Haushalte Interesse hätten, sind aber nur 12...
...Haushalte gekommen. Ja, das ist halt auch so...
...ein Problem, wenn die ganzen Rentner da sagen, ah...
...das braucht man nicht, und ach ja, mir reicht das doch.
Ja, gut.
Deutschland und Technologie...
...das hat noch nie gut funktioniert.
Die gucken wahrscheinlich auch, wo das nächste Faxgerät...
...steht. Letztes Mal...
...voll cringe sind irgendwelche Telekom-Leute...
...unangemeldet gekommen und meinten...
...was?
...dass in der Umgebung...
...dass in meiner Umgebung viele Leute sagten...
...dass hier viele Verbindungsfehler abbrüchen...
...das war bestimmt Scam.
Das waren bestimmt nicht mal Leute von der Telekom.
Das ist so eine Art von...
...Scam, die liest man immer wieder.
Ähm, das sind entweder...
...Vertreter, oder...
...die wollen dich ausrauben.
Ich hab dir doch letztes Video gezeigt, was du machst...
...wenn solche Leute vor dir stehen, oder?
Wir haben es uns doch eben...
...angeguckt, Home Defense.
Was macht man, Leute?
Wenn so welche...
...vor der Tür stehen?
Erstmal G18 Akimbo raus...
...und ein Property verteidigen.
Halt! Stopp!
Wie ging das weiter?
Halt! Stopp! Helfen Sie mir!
Wie ging das mit diesem...
...mit dem Typ, der erzählen wollte...
...wie können Sie sich...
...wehren?
Halt! Stopp! Bitte helfen Sie mir!
Halt! Stopp! Jetzt rede ich. Er hat doch...
...das gesagt mit, bitte helfen Sie mir.
Was kostet ein Glasfasertarif...
...so ungefähr?
Telekom...Glasfaser...
...okay.
Wir gucken mal hier unten.
Am schnellsten. Ja, ach, warum kann ich das nicht auswählen?
Gibt's nicht.
80 Euro im Monat.
Naja, ganz ehrlich...
...geht durchaus...
...in Ordnung. Zumal du bei der Telekom...
...einen vollwertigen IPv4, also...
...einen vollwertigen Dual-Stack-Anschluss bekommst...
...einen IPv4 und IPv6, also insofern...
...äh, mehr gibt's nix.
Hä?
Okay, der Slider ist ja mal maximal unsinnig.
Was soll denn...
...was um alles in der Welt soll dieser Slider bringen?
Guck mal, die Seite wäre...
...breit genug, einfach alles einzublenden.
Oh, die Seite ist breit genug.
Es macht überhaupt...
...der Slider macht absolut null Sinn!
Ja...
Ich mein, das ist bestimmt für super krasse...
...Responsive...
...Responsive Website.
Nee.
Guck mal, die Website ist nicht mal...
...richtig responsive.
Die ist so fake-responsive, ist die.
Voll teuer.
80 Euro, geht in Ordnung.
Wenn's vollwertiger...
...IPv4, IPv6-Anschluss ist...
...und Gigabit...
...guck mal, das ist schon nice.
Also, sobald's das gibt...
...bin ich dabei.
Aber warum nur 200 Upload-Speed?
Das ist in der Tat ziemlich...
...cringe.
Deutsche Glasfaser.
Guck mal, was die so haben.
Tarife.
DG Giga.
Siehst du, kostet das gleiche ungefähr.
Die haben sogar 500 ab, ja.
Also, warum die Telekom nur 200 MBit ab hat...
...verstehe ich auch nicht.
Tja...
...man weiß es nicht.
Aber eine Sache finde ich persönlich sehr nice, was Glasfaser-Dinger...
...angeht.
Es gibt sehr viele, auch jetzt regionale Anbieter...
...und mehrere Anbieter, die das machen.
Ähm...
...das steigert so ein bisschen den...
...die Durchsetzungs- oder...
...Einführungsgeschwindigkeit.
Es wird ja an jeder Ecke aktuell gebaut.
Also man sieht, wenn man will, geht das.
Und wir hätten das die letzten Jahre...
...über schon...
...wir hätten das die letzten...
...zehn Jahre über schon machen können, wenn wir gewollt hätten.
Und nicht...
...so sehr auf...
...und ja, komm mal hier so ab und zu mal...
...ein bisschen Gigabit über...
...Kabel ist doch auch Gigabit und...
...ja, wenn man sich schönrechnet mit Mobilfunk...
...dabei, ist das ja eigentlich auch...
...Breitband. Hätten wir...
...hätten wir mehr Energie darauf verwendet, die letzten...
...die letzten zehn Jahre über.
Ähm...
...ordentlich auszubauen, anstatt uns die Sache schön...
...zurechnen, wären wir jetzt schon deutlich weiter.
Aber ich bin froh, dass sich jetzt...
...aktuell was tut. Und ich glaube, dass sich was tut...
...sieht jeder auf der Straße, wenn...
...er mal so durch kleinere Orte läuft.
Vor 25 Jahren, Leute...
...hätte, hätte, hätte man immer machen können.
Aber die letzten zehn Jahre auf jeden Fall.
Ob die Technik vor 25 Jahren...
...heute noch...
...passend gewesen wäre...
...weiß man nicht.
Vielleicht ist es ganz gut, dass wir jetzt erst...
...so die letzten paar Jahre, wenn wir...
...bisschen später angefangen hätten, aber...
...zumindest mal fangen wir jetzt an.
Das ist das schon mal ganz gut.
Die Glasfaser ist...
...bis heute dasselbe.
Da wäre ich mir gar nicht mal unbedingt so sicher.
Je nachdem, was da verlegt wurde.
Wie es da mit der Wellenlänge...
...aussieht und ob da irgendwas gemultiplext...
...wird und ich kann ja das...
...legit nicht sagen.
Ob das mit der Infrastruktur von...
...1980er Jahren funktioniert hätte...
...heute.
Okay, mit 100 Euro im Monat ist es dann tatsächlich...
...ein bisschen teuer, aber ich würde es trotzdem bezahlen.
Gigabit...
...Poggers.
Das ist wahrscheinlich wirklich das Problem.
Ja, sauber.
Also die müssen...
...die sind ja auch aktuell überall wild am ausbauen.
Gerade wenn man durch kleinere Dörfer geht...
...und sowas sieht man das ja an allen Ecken, dass die...
...Straßen gerade aufgemacht werden und Glasfaser verlegt wird.
Das ist doch wunderbar.
Macht DSL heutzutage...
...noch Sinn oder eher Kabelinternet?
Der DSL macht schon Sinn, wenn dir das reicht...
...von der Geschwindigkeit her.
Kabelinternet ist, je nachdem mit wieviel...
...du das sharest, auch nicht immer...
...top, aber man kann sagen, im Durchschnitt...
...sicherlich heutzutage schneller...
...eine Bandbreite verfügbar als bei...
...DSL. Bei DSL hast du es halt exklusiv.
Auf der anderen Seite, ganz ehrlich...
...ich würde mir wahrscheinlich jetzt...
...keinen komplett neuen Internetanschluss...
...mehr holen, sondern wirklich warten, bis es...
...Glasfaserausbau gibt. Also wenn ich was...
...brauchbares hätte.
Ich würde beispielsweise jetzt keinen...
...keinen neuen...
...Vodafone-Tarif über zwei Jahre oder so abschließen.
Ganz ehrlich, sobald es hier was anderes gibt, bin ich...
...auch weg von Vodafone, richter Kackladen.
Nicht, dass die anderen unbedingt besser sind...
...oder vielleicht...
...kann durchaus sein, dass die anderen auch scheiße sind...
...aber von denen weiß ich zumindest noch nicht, dass sie...
...ob sie so sehr sacken...
...wie Vodafone.
Zumindest...
...habe ich eine Sache glücklicherweise...
...recht...
...geschickt gemacht die letzten Jahre...
...über nämlich, ich habe meine Festnetz-Telefonnummer...
...entkoppelt vom...
...Internet-Anbieter bzw. vom...
...Telefonanbieter.
Ich hatte ja jahrelang...
...so eine Festnetz-Nummer von der Telekom...
...die ursprünglich war...
...und die habe ich immer mit umgezogen...
...zu unterschiedlichen Anbietern, das war halt immer eklig...
...und die habe ich...
...seit ein paar Jahren...
...bei einem VoIP-Anbieter liegen...
...kostet 2,90 Euro im Monat...
...und das war eine gute Entscheidung, weil das ist jetzt...
...komplett unabhängig...
...vom...
...Internet-Provider oder vom Provider...
...den ich benutze, egal ob Vodafone, Telekom...
...deutsche Glasfaser, was auch immer...
...Vodafone funktioniert einfach immer weiter...
...solange ich einen Internet-Anschluss habe.
Benutzt du noch Festnetz?
Naja, wenn du eine Festnetz-Nummer hast seit...
...30 Jahren...
...oder fast 40 Jahren...
...dann ist es nicht so, dass du jetzt sagst...
...Hey, ich will heute alles weiter mit dem Festnetz machen...
...aber viele Leute haben halt...
...deine Festnetz-Nummer noch.
Die wirst du nicht von heute auf morgen einfach abschalten.
Ansonsten mache ich das meistens auch mit meinem Handy.
Wo wir in Deutschland...
...irgendwie die einzigen sind, die das so nennen.
Ja, wenn du einen Internet-Anschluss hast...
...der du direkt reinstecken kannst.
Es gibt ja auch andere...
...Techniken, ja.
Also, SFP-Plus-Ports sind es ja eh nicht.
Es sind ja meistens LC- oder SC-Ports.
Und...
...dann gibt es ja manchmal noch diese Dinger mit...
...Glasfaser kommt in so einen Medienwandler...
...und auf der anderen Seite kommt dann Gigabit-Kupfer raus...
...und sowas in der Richtung.
Also, ich denke mal mit einem SFP-Plus-Router...
...kommt man da wahrscheinlich gar nicht so weit.
Oder...
...sag mal so...
...ich habe zumindest noch kein SFP-Plus-Modul gesehen...
...mit so einem...
...single...
...LC-SC-Stecker...
...wie es bei manchen Glasfaserkabeln...
...für Gigabit-Internet ist.
Gibt es bestimmt. Letztendlich ist SFP-Plus...
...ja auch nur der Steckplatz.
Da gibt es dann alle möglichen Module.
Aber habe ich so zumindest noch nicht gesehen.
Keine Ahnung. Gibt es bestimmt auch.
Ich meine, es gibt ja auch...
...SFP-Plus-Module mit einem...
...245-Stecker an der anderen Seite.
Also warum soll es das nicht auch geben?
Ja.
Hast du das neue Zelda schon gespielt? Nein.
Ähm, und der Grund ist...
...ehrlich gesagt...
...ich warte bis das...
...im Emulator gut läuft.
Weil ich habe richtig Bock drauf.
Allerdings so...
...upscaled 60 FPS...
...wäre schon mega. Pogu?
Ja, und insofern...
...mal gucken.
Ja, aber es gibt wohl noch irgendwelche...
...Grafikprobleme und teilweise Crashes.
Habe ich gelesen.
Was cool wäre, wenn man den...
...weiß gar nicht, ob das geht...
...ob man irgendwie den Save von der Switch...
...extrahieren kann...
...und im Emulator weiterverwenden.
Okay.
Spielt ihr upscaled?
Oder spielt ihr auf 720p?
Läuft es in Barthesera?
Ja, das genau.
Das würde mich auch interessieren. Auf der anderen Seite...
...möchtest du im Desktop spielen. Der hat halt noch mehr Power.
Was ist meine...
...Emulatorkiste?
1440p 60.
Perfekt. Ja, da habe ich Bock drauf.
Ja, offiziell...
...wird das Nintendo nie raushauen...
...für einen PC.
Hat Nintendo jemals...
...irgendein Game für einen PC rausgebracht?
Also, das ist ja erst die letzten Jahre...
...über aufgekommen, dass gerade...
...einige Spiele von der Playstation...
...Jahre später dann mal...
...für einen PC kommen.
Also zum Beispiel...
...God of...
...das Vorletzte ist es jetzt ja...
...God of War kam ein bisschen später für einen PC...
...Horizon Zero Dawn kam für einen PC...
...und ich glaube...
...ja, die ganzen Final Fantasy Dinger...
...kommen mittlerweile auch für einen PC.
Das hat sich aber erst so die letzten Jahre über...
...so ein bisschen eingeschlichen...
...was Sony angeht...
...und PC-Releases.
Ich glaube, die God of War-Spiele waren auch ganz gut...
...auf dem PC.
Ich glaube, die liefen auch ganz gut.
Was heißt die ganzen God of War-Spiele?
Es gibt ja nur eins. Aber ich denke mal...
...dass es das Neue auch noch geben wird, irgendwann.
Wenn sie meinen, sie können damit...
...ein bisschen Kohle machen.
Oh, habt ihr die Kontroverse...
...mitgekriegt?
Um...
...um den letzten DLC...
...von...wie heißt...
...wie heißt das letzte Horizon-Game?
Horizon...
Nicht Zero Dawn. Zero Dawn war das erste.
Wie hieß das letzte?
Forbidden West. Genau.
Da gab es den DLC.
Und...
...da sind die Leute wieder richtig ausgerastet.
Nicht etwa wegen dem...
...Gameplay oder sonst was. Nein!
Weil es dort...
...Dialog-Optionen gibt...
...dass Aloy...
...einen weiblichen NPC...
...küssen kann. Und da haben die Leute...
...wieder komplett den...
...Untergang des Abendlandes...
...Herbei prophezeit.
Ganz, ganz schrecklich. Haben sich wieder...
...alle wahnsinnig drüber aufgegeben.
Dialog-Optionen. Das ist nicht so, als müsstest du das...
...machen.
Wahnsinnig.
Alle reingesteigert...
...und...
...komplett eskaliert wieder.
Spinnen alle.
Sicherlich kann man da die...
...Kritik anbringen. Wie gesagt, ich habe es nicht gespielt.
Ich weiß nicht, wie es umgesetzt ist.
Mal auf YouTube angeguckt.
Das ist eine...
...Dialog-Option.
Man muss das nicht machen. Klar sagen jetzt sicherlich...
...manche hier, das wäre so aufgesetzt...
...und sonst was. Endlich gesagt, keine Ahnung.
Das kann ich nicht beurteilen. Mag sein.
Möglich. Aber ich meine...
...nachdem du es immer noch im...
...Dialog einfach sein lassen kannst...
...juckt mich das nicht.
Und ich bilde mir sogar ein...
...dass es sogar...
...im Original, was das einzige ist...
...was ich ein bisschen gespielt habe...
...die ganze Horizon Game...
...dass es sogar im Original...
...Hinweise darauf gab...
...dass Aloy auf Frauen steht.
Weil, wenn ich das richtig im Hinterkopf...
...habe, war das ja so...
...dass...
...Aloy ist ja eigentlich...
...irgendwie so eine Art Klon...
...von irgend so einer Wissenschaftlerin...
...aus 2020.
Und...
...da gab es wohl Hinweise darauf, dass sie auf Frauen...
...steht. Und letztendlich ist mir das...
...aber bei einem Videogame-Charakter ehrlich gesagt...
...das ist scheißegal, ja.
Aber zumindest dieses Ultra-Aufgerege, egal...
...von welcher Seite, finde ich einfach immer total...
...bescheuert. Du hast auf der einen...
...Seite, die sich...
...drüber aufregen...
...es wird zu wenig...
...thematisiert...
...es wird zu wenig gemacht in Videospielen...
...und wenn dann Blizzard mal hingeht und sagt...
...Tracer ist lesbisch, dann regen sich alle...
...auf, ja, aber Tracer ist ein Charakter...
...der für das männliche Auge designt...
...wurde. Alter, riesen Shitstorm...
...nach Shitstorm. Und dann...
...kommt die andere Seite rum...
...und regt sich auf, oh nein...
...da hast du eine Dialogoption, wo der weibliche...
...Charakter einen anderen weiblichen Charakter...
...küssen kann. Oh, das ist ja...
...Vogue-Agenda und sonst was.
Leute, das ist einfach nur noch...
...Ultra-Circle-Jerk auf Twitter. Egal...
...was es ist, irgendeiner...
...regt sich immer des Todes auf.
Die Leute sind...
...einfach komplett durch, was das...
...angeht. Letztendlich, du kannst es...
...als Hersteller oder als Content-Creator...
...oder als, in irgendeiner Art und Weise...
...wenn du dich dazu äußerst oder was...
...du kannst es gar nicht irgendwie so sagen, dass...
...sich nicht irgendwie einer daran gestört fühlt.
Das am besten...
...ist tatsächlich...
...so blöd es klingt, das gar nicht zu...
...thematisieren.
Weil dann hast du zumindest deine Ruhe.
Guckt euch mal den armen Gronkh an, Alter.
Wie sie abgegangen sind bei ihm.
Das ist wirklich mittlerweile...
...alles nicht mehr normal.
How good is it really?
Cloudflare-Tunnel...
...weiß ich nicht, wie gut der ist.
Interessiert mich ehrlich gesagt heute auch mal gar nicht.
Normalerweise gucke ich mir die Videos von ihm gerne an.
Interessiert mich auch nicht.
Ich habe auch nicht vor, ihn zu benutzen.
Habt ihr mitgekriegt, dass dieser...
...Typ, der sein Flugzeug für ein Video...
...gecrashed hat, jetzt vor Gericht...
...muss? Es gab mal...
...vor einer Weile ein Video...
...crashed airplane?
Moment, der wurde...
...noch nicht verurteilt. Der wurde...
...nicht verurteilt bis jetzt.
Genau, dieser Dude hier, der hat ein Video gemacht.
Nein, nein, nein, Leute.
Das...
...das sind Ami-Strafen.
Die werden so wahrscheinlich...
...werden so wahrscheinlich nicht...
...nicht kommen, ja.
Das ist so, das könnte er...
...kriegen, aber ich...
...gestern oder so, wo ich geguckt habe, war der...
...war der noch nicht verurteilt.
Ich kann mir auch nicht vorstellen...
...dass der 20 Jahre dafür kriegt.
Er scheint ja auch kooperiert zu haben...
...ist zugegeben und sowas.
Zumindest, die Story dahinter...
...ist halt auch wieder richtig, richtig pepega.
Der Kerl hat ein Video gefilmt...
...was obviously...
...Hinweise drin...
...obvious Hinweise drauf hatte...
...dass es gefaked war.
Zum Beispiel, was ich halt persönlich...
...was ich halt schon...
...sehr auffällig fand...
...und zwar, irgendwann springt...
...er aus diesem Flugzeug raus...
...und, passt mal auf...
...er ist ja abgesprungen...
...passt mal auf...
...ja, ja...
...jetzt springt er ab...
...und man sieht...
...dass er in der Hose, hier hinten...
...hat einen Feuerlöscher versteckt.
Wo man sich dann fragt, Moment...
...warum hat einer einen versteckten...
...Feuerlöscher am Bein...
...wenn er doch gerade flüchten muss aus einem...
...aus einem...
...aus einem crashenden Flugzeug.
Übrigens, die GoPro-Kameras haben das auch alles ausgehalten.
Ja, zumindest...
...ja, der hat...
...einen Feuerlöscher hinten im...
...es gibt dann auch später noch Szenen, da sieht man dann den roten...
...Feuerlöscher rausgucken und sowas.
Er hat einen Feuerlöscher hier im...
...rum...
...warum trägt er das Headset noch, warum hat er die ganze Zeit sein...
...sein, ähm, Fallschirm...
...aufgehabt. Ja, also...
...die sind sich mittlerweile relativ sicher...
...nach den, ähm, diese, diese Flugaufsichtsbehörde...
...oder so bei den Amis...
...dass das wohl gefaked ist, und er muss es wohl...
...auch wenn ich das richtig gelesen habe...
...mittlerweile zugegeben haben...
...dass er das on purpose...
...gemacht hat, also dass er das quasi...
...eingefädelt hat, um Views...
...zu generieren.
So, so weit, so weit sind wir...
...schon. Auf der anderen Seite wundert...
...mich das nicht, Sekunde...
...auf der anderen Seite wundert mich das nicht...
...ich mein, es gibt deutsche...
...Youtuber, die um Reichweite zu...
...generieren, einen Bombenprank...
...machen.
Kritischer Hase sah ich...
...da nur zu. War das.
Was macht eigentlich der INSI-Modus?
Ist der durch mittlerweile?
Also, es wurde, es wurde auch schon...
...vom YouTube Deutschland...
...viel unüberlegtes, blödes Zeug gemacht.
Der hat vor zwei Wochen wieder was hochgeladen...
...okay.
Das, ist, ist der INSI-Modus jetzt beendet?
Weil das wäre eine ganz schön kurze Privatinsolvenz...
...gewesen. Geht sowas nicht irgendwie...
...keine Ahnung...
...lange? Fünf Jahre...
...oder so?
Wie lange geht...
...die Privatinsolvenz?
Drei Jahre?
What? Okay...
...so ganz...
...es geht länger. Drei Jahre...
...also...
...ich müsste das eigentlich...
...wissen, weil mein Vater hat eine Privatinsolvenz...
...hinter sich, aber wie gesagt...
...ich hab mit dem nicht allzu viel zu tun, ich hab das nur mitbekommen...
...dass er das gemacht hat...
...und ich bilde mir ein...
...das ging länger bei ihm als drei Jahre...
...ja...
...ja, ich glaube es auch, dass es fünf...
...waren bei ihm...
...okay, siehste mal Leute, hab ich keinen Plan von...
...ich hab nicht vor, eine Privatinsolvenz zu benötigen...
...jemals...
...hm...
...aber wisst ihr, was ich vorhab?
...mich privat...
...kranken zu versichern, noch bevor ich 40 bin...
...also quasi...
...dieses Jahr noch...
...weil verdienen tu ich mittlerweile genug...
...also sowohl was die Grenze angeht, als auch...
...an...
...monatlich, dass ich mir das leisten kann...
...plus...
...ne Berufs- und Fähigkeitsversicherung...
...das wird alles nicht billig, aber wenn ich mir...
...angucke...
...wie unglaublich viel Geld ich bezahle schon...
...an Krankenversicherungen und allem, ich hab letztens...
...auf meiner Gehaltsabrechnung geguckt...
...ist das auch drinne...
...warum?
...also ich mein, ich seh da aktuell...
...außer dass es, je nachdem wie man es macht...
...natürlich ins Geld gehen kann...
...rein...
...berufstechnisch...
...Also ja, Höchsteuersatz...
...aber nicht...
...den reichen Steuersatz...
...den nicht...
...ich weiß nicht wie das heißt...
...du hast ja Höchsteuersatz und dann nochmal...
...nen höheren Höchsteuersatz, den nicht...
...aber Höchsteuersatz...
...ich weiß es gar nicht, müsste ich mal reingucken...
...was mein Steuerberater da...
...vermutlich Höchsteuersatz...
...ja...
...wie kannst du berufsunfähig werden?
...man weiß ja nie in Frankfurt...
...das kann wahrscheinlich schneller passieren...
...als man denkt...
...leider nicht...
...ne Kai sag mal warum, interessiert mich...
...ich seh da bis jetzt für mich aktuell...
...aktuell eher...
...Vorteile...
...ich bezahl eh schon saumäßig viel Gebühren...
...und...
...insgesamt wird es sicherlich...
...ein bisschen teurer...
...wenn ich das aber noch abschließe bis ich 40 bin...
...und dementsprechend...
...das auch so plane alles...
...dass ich im Alter nicht...
...unverhältnismäßig viel mehr bezahle...
...erscheint das für mich ne sinnvolle...
...sinnvolle Sache zu sein...
...mich privat kranken zu versichern...
...du weißt...
...du weißt nie ob du dir später noch die Beiträge bezahlen kannst...
...gut, hey...
...das ist alles irgendwie ne Wette auf die Zukunft...
...du weißt auch nicht ob du später mal krank wirst...
...und es wirklich gut gebrauchen könntest...
...ordentlich behandelt zu werden...
...also das Argument kannst du theoretisch in beide Richtungen drehen...
...und...
...ich gehe ganz stark davon aus...
...dass ich die Beiträge...
...später noch bezahlen kann...
...erstens...
...will ich ne Berufsunfähigkeitsversicherung...
...also ne gescheide...
...Berufsunfähigkeitsversicherung...
...dabei haben, weil...
...wenn du wirklich mal berufsunfähig wirst...
...dann kannst du wahrscheinlich nicht bezahlen...
...ansonsten...
...hab ich...
...jetzt schon einiges Geld auf der hohen Kante...
...ich hab...
...mein ETF...
...Sparstelz...
...ich hab zwei Konten mit ordentlich Kohle drauf...
...also...
...es sieht durchaus danach aus als könnte ich den Beitrag...
...mein restliches Leben bezahlen...
...dankeschön...
...Sebasuchan...
...95...
...das klingt sehr nach einem Weep-Name...
...gut...
...das glaub ich dir Florian...
...ne Flozen...
...das glaub ich dir, wenn du da liegst...
...dann werden die wahrscheinlich...
...private und gesetzlich versicherte...
...beide versorgen, sodass sie nicht den Löffel abgeben...
...das kann ich mir durchaus vorstellen...
...ist ja auch gut so...
...ich mein ganz ehrlich...
...wär auch echt blöd, wenn das nicht so wär...
...aber bei allem anderen...
...ich hab das jetzt ja ein paar mal selbst am eigenen Leib schon...
...gespürt und gemerkt...
...also ich hab ein paar mal...
...jetzt schon selbst bezahlt beim Arzt...
...und ich hab auch beispielsweise schon mal...
...für meine Mutter einen Termin gemacht...
...mit Hüfte und sowas...
...ich kann euch sagen, es ist...
...komplett Unterschied...
...wie Tag und Nacht...
...erstens bei der Terminvergabe...
...sagen wir mal du willst einen Termin beim...
...Hautarzt haben für so jährliches...
...oder zweijährliches Hautkrebs...
...Vorsorge-Untersuchungs-Zeug...
...ich hab das wahrscheinlich auch schon gemacht...
...da wo man mit so einer Lupe...
...so einem Lichtding abgescannt wird...
...und geguckt wird, wie sind so...
...der Leberfleck, sieht das alles noch okay aus...
...also wenn du so...
...Hautkrebs-Vorsorge machen willst...
...da brauchst du bestimmt...
...wenn ich mir hier jetzt in Hanau einen Termin holen würde...
...bestimmt 3-4 Monate im Voraus...
...gut, kann man jetzt sagen...
...Hautkrebs-Vorsorge kann man ja im Vorfeld planen...
...aber ich sag euch das nur mal zum Vergleich...
...wenn ich da jetzt anrufen würde...
...ich kann euch übrigens...
...tatsächlich einen praktischen...
...ähm...
...wirklich was sagen aus eigener Erfahrung...
...ich hatte mal so einen ekligen...
...ähm...
...Black oben auf dem Kopf...
...da wusste ich nicht genau, was es ist...
...letztendlich hat sich einfach nur irgendwie...
...gut, was es war, kann ich euch...
...danach erzählen...
...so einen komischen Fleck...
...Fleck auf dem Kopf, und ich hab gedacht...
...häh, was ist das, wo kommt das her, was macht das da...
...und da hab ich angerufen...
...bei unserem Hausarzt, äh, nicht Hausarzt...
...Hautarzt, hab gesagt, hier...
...müsste mal einer gucken, und da kam die wirklich mit...
...um die Ecke, ich glaub irgendwie...
...sechs Wochen oder irgendwie, sieben Wochen...
...oder sowas in der Richtung...
...und da hab ich auch gemeint...
...moment, also, also mal angenommen...
...das ist jetzt wirklich was...
...gefährliches...
...also entweder in sieben Wochen ist mir der...
...ist mir der Kopf abgefault...
...oder es ist nichts schlimmes, da muss ich auch nicht mehr kommen...
...also, hab ich mal geguckt...
...nach, äh...
...Termin, also in Praxis...
...mit Terminvergaben für...
...für Private und Selbstzahler...
...du musst ja nicht privat versichert sein, um dich privat...
...behandeln zu lassen, du kannst es ja auch selbst bezahlen...
...so hab ich da angerufen...
...beim Hautarzt...
...hab gesagt, ich bezahl selbst...
...Leute, das war nicht so nach dem Motto...
...in sechs, sieben Wochen...
...das war so nach dem...ich hab ihr...
...ich hab ihr da gesagt am Telefon...
...an der Anmeldung gesagt, also...
...mir passt's eigentlich am besten montags...
...weil...
...ähm...
...ich hab halt montags immer frei...
...ich hab da irgendwie mittwochs...
...angerufen und so...
...und da meinte sie so irgendwie...
...ich bin grad in Frankfurt...
...auf der Arbeit und montags hab ich...
...immer frei, da meinte sie...
...ach, wenn sie eh schon hier in Frankfurt sind...
...wie sieht's denn heute Mittag aus?
...und das ist halt wirklich...
...das ist schon wirklich...
...ein krasser Unterschied, oder?
...sieben Wochen versus...
...kommen sie mal heute Mittag schnell vorbei...
...so und man könnte jetzt vielleicht...
...sagen, hey das ist so ein Einzelfall...
...gewesen, ja, ich hab halt...
...nen Hautarzt erwischt in Hanau...
...der mega viel zu tun hatte...
...und...
...in Frankfurt ein, der halt...
...Däumchen dreht den ganzen Tag, aber...
...nicht nur das, ich hab das ja noch ein paar mal gemacht, ja...
...ich war beispielsweise mal...
...bei einem HNO...
...zweimal schon bei einem HNO-Arzt...
...und hab selbst bezahlt, easy...
...so nach dem Motto...
...ähm...
...kommen sie morgen vorbei...
...ich war, für meine Mutter hab ich einen Termin gemacht...
...beim Orthopäde...
...und war hier...
...eine Woche Montag, passt wunderbar...
...und die Behandlung war wirklich gut...
...das kann ich nochmal sagen...
...ähm, die war...
...also meine Mutter hat Hüftpulverprobleme gehabt...
...und die hat da irgendwie...
...irgendwas im Gelenk hat sich entzündet...
...ich mein, die ist auch schon über 70...
...kommt sowas mal vor...
...und die hat Gelenkprobleme gehabt...
...und die hat Wochen...
...und Monat lang...
...so dumpfe Schmerzen...
...24-7 in der Hüfte gehabt, ja...
...die war beim Hausarzt...
...der Hausarzt hat ihr zweimal...
...ähm, Schmerzmittel gegeben...
...vam zweiten Mal...
...Schmerzmittel an dem Tag...
...hat sie Herzprobleme davon bekommen...
...und muss ins Krankenhaus...
...Leute, da hab ich's mit der Angst zu tun gekriegt...
...ich kann euch sagen, ey...
...wenn euch eure Mutter anruft...
...aufm Handy und sagt, sie hat Herzprobleme...
...ruft mal den Notarzt...
...da macht ihr euch halb in die Hose...
...das kann ich euch sagen...
...es gibt halt Leute, von denen möchte man nicht, dass sie sterben...
...die Eltern gehören ja da in der Regel dabei...
...und da hab ich's erst mal...
...schon ein bisschen mit der Angst zu tun gekriegt...
...Äh, Notarzt gerufen, da hab ich dann...
...hab ich sogar auf Twitter, Twitter gepostet, hier...
...Twitter, Notarzt, äh, Max, Max FPS...
...Notarzt, oder...
...äh, nein, was auch immer...
...Twitter, hab ich ja sogar...
...hab ich ja sogar gepostet auf, auf Twitter...
...nachts, wo ich in der...
...ähm, ja...
...also, da hab ich ja nachts oder...
...spätabends mit, mit ihrem Krankenhaus...
...aufnahme gesessen...
...ja, das war die Kurzfassung, natürlich...
...hat sie nicht bei mir angerufen, hat gesagt, Max, ruf mal...
...den Notarzt an, die hat bei mir angerufen...
...hat gemeint, sie hat, äh, sie hat irgendwie...
...Herzrhythmusstörungen oder so...
...Herzprobleme...
...und, ähm, dann, äh, als...
...als ich dann unten bei ihr gewesen bin, hab ich gesagt...
...wir rufen jetzt den Notarzt an, das war die Kurzfassung...
...sehe ich jetzt gar so sehr...
...also sehr ausbreitend...
...zumindest...
...gehen wir bis heute relativ stark davon aus...
...dass das ausgelöst wurde durch diese...
...durch diese Schmerzmittel...
...die sie da bekommen hat...
...weil sie beim ersten Mal schon ein bisschen Probleme hatte...
...und danach hat sie immer noch Hüftprobleme gehabt...
...natürlich, ja, das geht ja nicht, wenn du mit Herzproblemen...
...ins Krankenhaus angeliefert wirst, gehen dir deine Hüftprobleme...
...nicht weg davon...
...im Krankenhaus wollte sich das natürlich keiner angucken...
...dann war sie danach, äh, nochmal bei irgendeinem anderen Orthopäde...
...dann war sie bei einer...
...bei irgendeinem Orthopäden-Dings...
...Zentrum im Krankenhaus...
...und das war eh der Hit...
...die haben das geultraschallt...
...die haben das nicht mehr erkennen müssen, dass das Gelenk...
...entzündet ist, ja...
...die haben das geultraschallt und haben zu ihr...
...und haben ihr schon während dem Ultraschall...
...was erzählt von Hüftoperationen...
...müsst ihr euch mal vorstellen...
...die hat überhaupt nichts an der Hüfte, was operiert werden muss...
...die haben ihr beim Ultraschall...
...beim Ultraschall haben sie ihr schon erzählt...
...man könnte ja eine Hüftoperation machen...
...und am Ende kam halt raus...
...ach nee, es ist doch nichts, wo man operieren muss...
...und anstatt der was dagegen gemacht hat...
...im Krankenhaus...
...gegen der Entzündung im Gelenk...
...hab ich sie reingeschickt mit...
...ach, nehmen sie Schmerztabletten...
...und geht schon wieder von allein weg...
...und das wohlgemerkt mit dem Hinweis...
...dass sie Schmerztabletten, diese Art von Schmerztabletten...
...die sie nehmen soll, nicht verträgt...
...verträgt sie nicht, weil sie...
...Magenprobleme hat, ist auch egal...
...und so, da hab ich gesagt...
...weißt du was, Mama, jetzt reicht's...
...wir machen das jetzt anders...
...ich hatte ja in der Zeit schon ein bisschen Erfahrung gesammelt...
...weil ich selbst schon ein paar mal...
...selbstbezahlt zum Arzt gegangen bin...
...ich hab gesagt, Mama, es reicht jetzt...
...ich hab die Autopäde an, ich wusste...
...ich hab mal selbst für mich geguckt...
...und wusste, dass am Hauptbahnhof einer ist...
...die...
...der...
...super Bewertungen hat...
...ich hab mal selbst überlegt, ob ich da hingehe...
...zu Zeiten, wo ich noch so Rückenprobleme hab, weil ich zu wenig Sport gemacht hab...
...ist ja glücklicherweise...
...glücklicherweise alles...
...gefixt mittlerweile durch...
...wer hätte es gedacht...
...mehr Bewegung...
...naja, zumindest...
...hab ich da angerufen, hab gesagt...
...hier, da und da, so sieht's aus...
...Probleme...
...und da haben die gesagt, ja, kommen sie dann und dann vorbei...
...das war, keine Ahnung, drei Tage später oder so...
...konnten wir da vorbei, montags...
...genau, weil ich weiß, ich hatte ja frei...
...montags konnten wir vorbeikommen...
...und ich muss euch sagen, Leute, es war ein Unterschied wie Tag und Nacht...
...also...
...insgesamt, ich war ja bei beiden...
...Behandlungsterminen mit dabei...
...ich meine, ich musste den Kram im Endeffekt auch bezahlen, ja...
...dabei...
...und insgesamt...
...waren wir beim Arzt...
...20 Minuten drinnen, ja, das erste Mal...
...das erste Mal irgendwie so...
...paaren 20 und das nächste Mal noch 10 Minuten...
...zum, zum gucken...
...der hat genau das gleiche gemacht wie im Krankenhaus...
...hat, ähm, das, das...
...geultraschallt, hat gesagt, ja, okay, wahrscheinlich...
...ist das wirklich sowas, vermutet wurde...
...äh, Entzündung im Gelenk...
...hat dann noch irgendwelche Einrenkübungen gemacht...
...und hat ihr irgendeine...
...ja, frag mich so, Abschwelldesinfektion...
...antibakteriell, keine Ahnung...
...Spritze da ins, ins Gelenk gegeben...
...das ist ja auch was, da hätte ich keinen Bock drauf gehabt...
...das ist bestimmt schmerzhaft...
...so, und...
...dann war das Ganze...
...das Ganze war nach zwei Wochen wieder weg...
...nach zwei Wochen war das Ganze wieder weg...
...und der hat sich Monate rumgeschlagen im Vorfeld damit...
...nach, nach irgendwie eineinhalb Wochen...
...zwei Wochen waren wir nochmal da...
...und hat auch gesagt, alles gut jetzt...
...er hat nochmal Ultraschall gemacht, hat gesehen, aha, die Entzündung ist...
...die Entzündung ist auch wieder weg...
...ja, ja...
...und, so sieht's aus...
...da wurde man halt ordentlich behandelt...
...und 40, 45 Minuten da insgesamt drin...
...das ist mehr, als ich meinen...
...meinen Hausarzt wahrscheinlich in den letzten drei Jahren...
...gesehen hab...
...zusammen, in den letzten fünf Jahren wahrscheinlich...
...ja...
...und deswegen...
...nachdem ich persönlich selbst so gute Erfahrungen bisher...
...damit gemacht hab...
...hab ich mir jetzt überlegt, okay, anstatt...
...massig 800 Euro...
...oder sowas...
...für gesetzliche Versicherungen zu bezahlen...
...irgendwie sowas in dem Dreh stand auf meiner letzten...
...Gehaltsabrechnung drauf...
...hab ich auch mich privat versichern lassen...
...der Arbeitgeber bezahlt ja immer noch...
...den Anteil weiter...
...was hast du gezahlt? Ah, da sag ich gleich was zu...
...weil da kamen eben noch ein paar mehr Fragen zu...
...äh, ist so...
...ja, vielen Dank für den Zap...
...das ist so...
...ähm...
...ich war jetzt ja schon als Selbstzahler...
...bei ein paar privaten Praxen oder halt...
...bei ein paar welchen, die gesetzlich versichern...
...und Privatpatienten nehmen...
...das ist so, die haben getrennte Wartezimmer...
...oftmals...
...dass...
...es eben kein Unmut gibt...
...dass dort irgendein Dude reinkommt...
...5 Minuten später zum Arzt darf...
...und ein anderer 45 Minuten wartet...
...das hat schon seinen Grund...
...sicherlich könnte man auch sagen, ja...
...das private Wartezimmer hat komfortable Stühle...
...blablabla...ich bin mir sicher der Hauptgrund ist...
...dass die das voneinander nicht so sehr mitbekommen...
...weil...
...da wäre ich auch pisst...
...wenn ich sehen würde, dass irgendeiner gerade reingekommen ist...
...und direkt rein darf...
...versus ich sitze 45 Minuten im Wartezimmer...
...logisch...
...wäre ich da pisst...
...ist so...
...ne...also...
...dazu kann man nur sagen, das ist nicht so...
...die können sich nicht irgendwas ausdenken...
...es gibt zwei Sachen...
...also was heißt zwei Sachen...
...es gibt eigentlich eine Sache, die ihr machen...
...nein zwei Sachen...
...zwei Sachen, die ihr machen könnt, wenn ihr nicht privat versichert seid...
...aber zu einem Arzt gehen wollt...
...und selbst bezahlen...
...das erste ist...
...in jedem anderen Laden...
...wo ihr irgendwelche Dienstleistungen kauft...
...schon im Vorfeld mal fragen...
...mit was muss man denn grob rechnen...
...natürlich wissen die nicht...
...die werden euch dann sagen...
...ja, kommt immer ein bisschen drauf an, was gemacht werden muss...
...aber erstmal so eine Standarduntersuchung...
...mit...
...dem, dem und dem...
...so und so viel...
...das ist das erste...
...das zweite ist...
...ihr könnt fragen...
...mit welchem Satz...
...die standardmäßig abrechnen...
...weil es gibt so eine Gebührenordnung...
...da steht drinnen...
...also auch ein privater Arzt kann sich nicht...
...einfach random was aus den Fingern saugen...
...zumindest nicht ohne euch das vorher zu sagen...
...was verschiedene...
...verschiedene Tätigkeiten kosten...
...es gibt eine Gebührenordnung...
...G-G-O-Ä oder so heißt das Ding...
...da gibt es für...
...naher zu alle Dienstleistungen, die ein Arzt erbringen kann...
...gibt es Tabellen...
...da drin steht...
...was die kosten...
...so und dann gibt es einen Faktor...
...wie viel der...
...also mal wie viel das genommen wird...
...ja also normalerweise ist 1...
...also sprich das was in der Tabelle steht...
...und da könnt ihr den Arzt mal fragen...
...mit welchem Faktor er standardmäßig abrechnet...
...die meisten rechnen mit 2,5 oder 2,8 ab...
...mehr dürfen sie...
...soweit ich weiß auch gar nicht...
...ohne das explizit im Vorfeld zu sagen...
...also sprich...
...die dürfen maximal sagen wir mal...
...einfach abrechnen von dem was in der Tabelle steht...
...also wenn ihr...
...nix großartiges macht...
...kann das gar keine...
...riesenrechnung geben...
...also es sei denn man sagt euch das...
...explizit im Vorfeld...
...wie gesagt wenn ihr fragt...
...mit was muss man so ungefähr rechnen...
...beziehungsweise fragt...
...mit welchem Satz die abrechnen...
...standardmäßig...
...dann wissen sie zumindest schon mal...
...dass ihr ein bisschen Ahnung habt wovon ihr redet...
...und zweitens können sie euch dann auch nicht sonst irgendwie...
...irgendwelche Märchen erzählen...
...ja kannst du halt nicht...
...also du kriegst...
...keine Überraschungsrechnung...
...und auf die Frage rauf hin...
...woviel ich bezahlt habe beim Orthopäde...
...okay...
...Chat...
...ratet mal...
...also ich war mit meiner Mutter beim Orthopäde wir waren insgesamt...
...sagen wir mal 2x 20 Minuten drinnen...
...um es einfacher zu machen...
...Hüfte wurde behandelt mit Ultraschall...
...Ehm...
...und...
...Gespräch erklären und allem...
...und dann nochmal kontrolliert...
...was meint ihr was das ganze gekostet hat am Ende...
...450, 500...
...also ich sag euch mal mit was ich gerechnet habe...
...ich persönlich habe auch mit...
...irgendwas um 300 bis 400 Euro gerechnet...
...sag ich euch...
...ganz ehrlich...
...am Ende hat es 105 Euro gekostet...
...also die Leute die 100 Euro gesagt haben war gar nicht so schlecht...
...105 Euro hat es gekostet...
...und da muss ich doch ehrlich sagen...
...ich meine...
...ich habe nicht viel gemacht...
...aber trotzdem...
...und nicht 2 Stunden...
...2x 20 Minuten...
...und da muss ich sagen...
...also dafür...
...dass man so gut behandelt wurde...
...der auch erklärt hat was er macht...
...man ihn fragen konnte und sich Zeit genommen hat...
...und vor allem das wichtigste...
...dass es geholfen hat...
...ist das vollkommen in Ordnung...
...also ich hätte auch 200-300 Euro für bezahlt...
...400 auch...
...und jetzt geht es wieder besser...
...ich habe die aber auch im Vorfeld gefragt...
...wie sie abrechnen...
...und die meinten mit einfachem Satz...
...das heißt also quasi nur das was in der Tabelle steht...
...ohne krasse Zuschläge...
...oder ohne verdoppeln und verdreifachen...
...das ist relativ selten wie gesagt...
...die meisten rechnen standardmäßig...
...mal 2,5 mal 2,8 ab...
...aber der hat von Anfang an ganz klar gesagt...
...er rechnet nur...
...es sei denn es ist irgendwie ein Sonderfall...
...es wird mega kompliziert...
...er rechnet nur mit einfachem Satz ab...
...und ich habe trotzdem...
...mit mehr Geld gerechnet ganz ehrlich...
...ich hätte auch irgendwie so mit 300-400 Euro...
...gerechnet...
...aber 105 Euro...
...konnte ich echt nicht beschweren...
...ja so ein bisschen schon...
...genau das ist das erste was ich sage...
...ich mache Twitter Post für euch...
...hast du deinen Agila verkauft...
...ja habe ich...
...genau ich hätte sagen müssen Leute...
...lasst mich mal schneller ran ich mache Twitter Post für euch...
...sehr gute perfekte Idee...
...so kriegt man Termine...
...ja und das ist halt ein Vorteil...
...wenn man den Kram selbst bezahlt oder privat versichert...
...es geht halt einfach schneller...
...und nicht nur schneller...
...die Behandlung ist auch besser weil die sich einfach...
...mehr Zeit nehmen und oftmals ist Zeit...
...ja auch ein ausschlaggebender...
...Faktor bei vielen Sachen...
...also sowohl in der Geschwindigkeit...
...je nachdem was du hast umso schneller man das behandelt...
...und merkt umso besser...
...aber auch Zeit mit...
...dass du mal deinem Arzt was erklären kannst...
...dass der auch...
...fragen kann und man kann da mal kurz drüber reden...
...also man findet ja schon ganz viele Sachen raus...
...woran es liegen könnte oder was die Probleme sind...
...wenn man einfach nur mit den Leuten...
...reden kann...
...und nicht in 2,5 Minuten...
...5 Leute durch haben muss...
...und eigentlich nur noch die Krankmeldung...
...unterschreibt...
...danke fürs ans Trinken erinnern Leute...
...hab ich gerade gemacht...
...wie gesagt 105 Euro...
...Mister Moogame Pog Subscription...
...dankeschön...
...ne das hatte ich bis jetzt noch nicht...
...ich wurde schon mal ein bisschen gescamt...
...ich war mal...
...bei einem HNO Arzt in...
...Frankfurt...
...da habe ich morgens angerufen...
...weil irgendwie war mein Ohr verstopft...
...ich habe auf der einen Seite...
...auf dem einen Ohr nichts mehr gehört...
...das war schon ein bisschen doof...
...und...
...da habe ich da angerufen und gefragt...
...ob die das mal...
...sich angucken können...
...gut im Endeffekt musst du da halt das ausspülen und sauber machen...
...und keine Ahnung...
...so dass das halt wieder geht...
...und die haben auch gesagt...
...kommen sie mittags vorbei...
...bin ich in der Mittagspause hin...
...wunderbar...
...und die haben halt nichts anderes gemacht...
...wie halt mit diesem Sauger...
...und mit Licht...
...das was sich da irgendwie festgesetzt hat...
...da im Gang...
...rauszumachen...
...was übrigens jedem von euch passieren kann...
...hat mir auch mal ein Arzt erklärt...
...also das ändert sich...
...auch über die Jahre...
...je nachdem...
...wo sich im Ohr was ablagert...
...und wo da was produziert wird...
...also ihr könnt noch so gut...
...eure Ohren sauber machen...
...ihr könnt trotzdem immer sowas haben...
...ja Bock hätte ich da auch nicht...
...hätte ich da auch nicht drauf das sauber machen zu müssen...
...und zumindest am Ende...
...haben sie mir halt irgendwie glaube ich fast 70€ abgerechnet...
...
...und auf der Rechnung Leute...
...auf der Rechnung...
...standen Dinger drauf...
...das haben die im Leben nicht gemacht...
...da stand was von Beratungsgespräch...
...mikroskopischer Untersuchung...
...nichts davon haben sie gemacht...
...das einzige was die gemacht haben ist...
...so ein Sauger zu nehmen...
...und ein Licht...
...und ins Ohr zu gucken und das sauber zu machen...
...ja also...
...aber ich mein...
...ich hab mich nicht großartig beschwert...
...ich hab morgens angerufen...
...konnte in der Mittagspause hin...
...allein schon dafür war es mir das irgendwie wert...
...ah ne aber danke für das erinnern...
...hab ich gerade schon gemacht...
...PV Ike...
...ich weiß nicht wie ich es anders aussprechen soll...
...danke für den Prime-Sub...
...wird die Private im Alter...
...nicht mega teuer...
...das kommt drauf an wie man es macht...
...in der Regel sagt man nach 40...
...lohnt sich es ja nicht mehr...
...was übrigens auch der Grund ist warum ich jetzt noch V40 machen will...
...ähm...
...man kann das so planen...
...dass man...
...früher mehr einzahlt...
Dass man im Alter nicht mehr bezahlt
Oder theoretisch sogar im Alter weniger bezahlen muss
Ich glaube da gibt es dann Tarife
Damit du im Alter quasi entlastet wirst
Ja
Natürlich
Unterm Strich musst du alles das bezahlen
Früher oder später
Wieso ist das denn so
Du meinst die bessere Behandlung
Das ist ganz einfach
Weil du von
Weil du privat viel mehr Geld abrechnen kannst
Für die gleiche Dienstleistung
Als bei der gesetzlichen Krankenversicherung
Geld kriegt er bei beiden
Aber der bekommt einfach mehr dafür
Und weil der mehr bekommt
Kannst du halt dir auch erlauben
Beispielsweise mal
Einen Patienten 15 Minuten zu behandeln
Und mit dem in Ruhe zu reden
Und überlegen was können wir machen
Anstatt dass du in der gleichen Zeit
3-4 Leute durchprügeln musst
Die haben einfach mehr Zeit
Unterm Strich
Weil sie besser abrechnen können
Deswegen sind die auch so
So zuvorkommend
Gegenüber Privatversicherten
Und selbstbezahlenden Leuten
Weil das einfach Geld bringt
In der gleichen Zeit
Deutlich mehr Geld
Als gesetzlich versichert
Natürlich muss man sagen
Da müssen sie aber halt auch
Ein bisschen was für machen
Also du musst
Dann als Arzt schon
Die Leute auch davon überzeugen
Wieder zu dir zu gehen
Weil du hast halt die Auswahl
Wenn du privatversichert bist
Und wenn du nicht versichert bist
Oder halt die Sachen selbst bezahlt
Dann kannst du heute sagen
Nö kein Bock mehr auf den Dude
Ich gehe einfach woanders hin
Und es stehen halt da nicht Schlange
Wenn er halt sagt
Stehen halt nicht bei ihm Schlange
Die Leute Schlange
Wohingegen wenn du gesetzlich versichert
Arzt bist mit Kassenzulassung
Der gesetzlich Versicherte nimmt
Dann stehen sie ja
Die Leute Schlange
Ob du jetzt gut bist oder nicht
Weil Leuten die gut sind sogar noch mehr
Und die Leute
Also ja du musst halt auch
Auf was auf die Reihe kriegen als Arzt
Wenn du viele Privatversicherte haben willst
Was eigentlich ganz gut ist ja
Dass du dich ein bisschen anstrengen musst
Aber auf der anderen Seite die Leute halt auch
Dann ein besseres Gefühl haben
Gut behandelt worden zu sein
Und Leute ich kann euch sagen
Es ist schon einfach ein ganz anderes
Du fühlst du fühlst dich
Es macht einen Unterschied
Also würde ich sagen
Man hat einfach ein deutlich besseres Gefühl
Wenn der Arzt mal 5 Minuten Zeit hat
Mit dir zu reden
Anstatt nur die Krankmeldung unterschreiben
Anstatt nur die Krankmeldung zu unterschreiben
Du gehst dann mit einem deutlich beruhigteren
Gefühl raus
Und ich könnte mir vorstellen
Keine Ahnung ob es dazu Studien gibt
Dass das aber auch
Für die Genesung nicht verkehrt ist
Also wenn die Leute sich gut behandelt fühlen
Und beruhigt
Da rausgehen und keine Panik mehr schieben
Und sowas das irgendwas ist
Dass das auch dazu beiträgt
Dass sie schneller wieder gesund sind
Sag ich jetzt einfach mal
Ohne
Zu wissen ob es dafür Studien gibt
Aber ich würde wundern wenn es nicht so wäre
Kassensula sind begrenzt
Ja wie gesagt
Die super Argumente
Dagegen habe ich jetzt immer noch nicht gehört
Also man außer die
Außer die Bedenken
Dass man halt vielleicht die Beiträge nicht mehr zahlen kann
Aber wie gesagt
Du kannst auch
Das ist ja alles eine Wette auf die Zukunft
Im Endeffekt wenn du darauf wettest
Dass du nie krank wirst
Ist es verschenkt
Du könntest aber genauso gut
In drei Jahren
Mal was ernstes haben
Wo du dich freust
Dass du es erstens nicht selbst bezahlen musst
Und zweitens
Bessere Behandlung kriegst
Mit lebensnotwendigen geht man keine Wette ein
Das ist doch das was ich sage
Dann ist ja gerade in dem Fall
Sinnvoll sich privat zu versichern
Oder?
Wenn du es aus dem Gesichtspunkt siehst
Letztendlich sind Versicherungen immer eine Wette
Auf die Zukunft
Egal wie du siehst
Und wenn man halt davon ausgeht
Gerade wenn du dich zu was lebenswichtigem absichern willst
Dann müsstest du ja erst recht sagen
Ja mach ich
Deswegen Zusatzversicherung
Da kann ich jetzt nicht so viel qualifiziert
Was zu sagen
Weil das habe ich mir vor der Weile mal angeguckt
Aber aus irgendeinem Grund
Hat sich das für mich nicht so
Nicht so angeboten
Ich weiß aber nicht mehr warum
Genau
Wenn ich das nicht so anbiete
Wenn ich damit rechne dass ich nie krank wäre
Ja dann würde ich es auch nicht machen
Ja
Das stimmt
Wenn man Kinder hat und Familie
Und die mitversichern will
Dann lohnt sich das nicht
Was da frage ich mich
Geh zum Arzt und zahle privat
Der macht ein Rezept für Krankengymnastik
Das wird
Ne
Ähm
Naja
Wenn er beide Zulassungen hat
Weiß ich nicht ob was er da
Also ne
Also kannst normalerweise nicht
Zu einem privaten
Zu einem rein privaten Arzt gehen
Und dort
Beispielsweise
Irgendwelche Überweisungen bekommen
Für gesetzliche Krankenversicherungsleistungen
Ne das geht nicht
Äh
Der kann dich aber genauso gut krank schreiben
Und sowas
Das geht
Also du kannst ohne Probleme
Zu einem rein privaten Arzt gehen
Und der schreibt dich krank
Ja
Das gibt's
Das geht
Das ist kein Problem
Äh was du nicht machen kannst ist
Du gehst zu einer rein privaten Praxis
Und kriegst eine Überweisung zur gesetzlichen Krankengymnastik
Das geht nicht
Wenn du einen hast der privat und gesetzliche Zulassungen hat
Ja wer weiß nicht
Vielleicht drehen die da irgendwas
Wo ist das der Fall
Vielleicht bei
Ne
Ja vielleicht bei Zahnersatz
Oder wobei selbst da ist es
Was das gesetzliche angeht ziemlich kacke
Da musst du auch die meisten Sachen selbst bezahlen
Das wundert mich in der Tat auch nicht
Klar
Da kannst du Geld verdienen
S-Fuck
Das stimmt schon
Das wundert mich nicht
Da muss man sicherlich
Ein Auge drauf haben
Wenn die dir erzählen
Ah ok
Dann lassen sie uns doch in 2 Wochen nochmal gucken
Ach und jetzt in 2 Wochen vielleicht nochmal
Was ist denn das
Auch schon
Ja bestimmt
Bestimmt
Ja
Jo
Also das wie gesagt
Das habe ich noch vor
Pdvor ich 40 bin
Private Krankenversicherung
Und ich mein erstmal
Muss ich mich weiter schlau machen
Dazu
Ich werd nicht von heute auf morgen
Eine abschließen
Ja
Das sag ich euch gleich
Ich werd dann nicht irgendwen Blödsinn
So nach dem Motto
Heute is mir's danach
Aber das ist auf jeden fall ein Thema
Das steht bei mir
Auf der Agenda
Wie man so schön sagt
Also private Krankenversicherung
Und ne berufsunfähigkeitsversicherung
Gerade das in Kombination erscheint mir schon sinnig.
Und ich könnte mir schon durchaus vorstellen, dass sich das lohnt,
wobei das bestimmt von Einzelfall zu Einzelfall verschieden ist.
Wisst ihr?
Aber alles, was ich bisher an Erfahrung gemacht habe,
somit ich bezahle es mal selbst,
war um Längen angenehmer und besser als das, was ich mit...
Ich gehe mal gesetzlich hin hatte.
Es ist einfach...
Unterschied wie Tag und Nacht, ja.
Die sind viel netter, weil sie mehr Zeit haben,
sind aufmerksamer, was man ihnen erzählt, hören einem zu, sagen was.
Also, unterm Strich muss ich sagen,
ich gehe viel lieber zu einem Arzt, wo ich selbst bezahle,
oder halt zu einem privaten, als zu einem gesetzlichen.
Und ich gehe auch mit einem besseren Gefühl raus am Ende.
Na gut, aber jetzt genug über irgendwelche Krankheiten oder sonstige Geschichten.
Können wir uns doch irgendwas angucken jetzt mal.
Zeigt mal her.
Haben wir noch irgendwas, was wir uns schnell...
schnell geben können, bevor Boomer müde, Boomer schlafen, Bett getimt ist?
Was ist das?
How this SQL command blew up a billion dollar company.
Der zeigt uns jetzt aber nicht...
dieses Meme mit dem Drop Table auf dem Auto-Kennzeichen, oder?
What the fuck?
Chat?
Chatge, was ist hier los?
Haben wir schon das Hitler-Protip...
Ja, haben wir uns schon angeguckt.
Haben wir uns schon angeguckt.
Gatschib, Gatschib.
Ja, ja, ich hab's...
Ich hab's in der Vorschau noch gesehen, Gatschibas.
Warum?
Was?
Heartland?
Hab ich noch nie was davon gehört.
Scheint schon ein bisschen...
Drop Table User Store.
Oh, das sieht...
Das sieht schon mal...
Das sieht schon mal gefährlich aus.
Komm, wir gucken uns das jetzt an.
Wir gucken uns das jetzt an.
Was, was...
Das ist aber auch schon ein bisschen älter, oder?
Das ist Low-Res Bildschirm.
Was natürlich nie passiert ist.
Was ich übrigens eben meinte, ist das hier.
Job, Tables, ähm...
Oh, mein Schild.
Also, seriously, ich hab keine Ahnung, ob das überhaupt, ob das wirklich funktioniert hat,
oder ob das einfach nur so ein, äh, irgendein, irgendein Meme-Bild, Bild ist, ja?
Aber, ich mein, womöglich halte ich vieles in der Richtung.
Okay.
Kind of sat there stealing data for months.
Well, that'd be pretty bad.
Let's hope that never happens.
A few cybercrime enthusiasts were enjoying their typical Wednesdays,
Sifting through hundreds of websites, trying to find one that was susceptible to their attacks.
Most notably, SQL injection.
One resided in Miami, Florida, while the others were from Russia.
Ah.
The Commodore Time.
A few websites we can hack.
Send it over. Let me take a look.
Sure, boss.
Haven looked at what database they're using, but definitely not synetized.
Bro, is this a joke?
We're not gonna make any money from this.
Remember, we're gonna get rich or die trying.
Yeah, but I was hungry.
Fine.
I also have a second one.
Take a look.
Moment, hat der hier Hollywood grad laufen?
Sieht ein bisschen so aus, oder?
Fine.
I also have a second one.
Take a look.
Jackpot.
Oh, Microsoft SQL, ja, dann wundert mich nix mehr.
SQL is a programming language used to query databases.
For example, when you search for spaghetti on Amazon,
a SQL query will be made for spaghetti.
In the product table to return all of the spaghetti.
Das halte ich, ich mein, das ist nur ein Beispiel,
aber das halte ich für ein Gerücht, dass es bei Amazon so direkt funktioniert.
SQL injection is one of the most common cyber attacks,
and I've left a link in the description for a great walkthrough
on how it can be carried out.
Quick summary though, the user passes SQL code as input,
which the application places into a query.
However, this extra SQL code changes the meaning of the query,
causing an unintended failure.
This is the output, and this output is then used elsewhere in the application,
causing unintended behavior.
Launch code accepted.
Sending nukes in 3, 2, 1.
The hackers didn't find any interesting content in this database.
They also weren't just trying to log in as some user to the web portal,
as that would be easily detectable and simply too small in scope.
They had much bigger plans in mind.
The database they had access to was Microsoft SQL Server 2000,
also, wie alt? Moment, Moment, Moment, wie alt ist das?
The database they had access to was Microsoft SE...
Also entweder ist das Ganze schon vor Urzeiten passiert,
oder es ist ja wirklich fahrlässig damit noch...
rum zu hantieren.
SQL Server 2000.
SQL Server uses it's own Transact SQL or T-SQL Querying Language,
which is basically SQL with a fancy hat.
SQL Server has...
Leute!
SQL oder SQL?
SQL.
2008 rum war das, okay.
Ich bin auch für SQL.
SQL, beste.
Er hört sich ja auch sehr begeistert an beim Vortragen des Videoskripts.
Ja, okay, lassen wir es mal so stehen.
Stimmt ja so nicht, aber.
Ah, beste Sache.
Sowas sollte man unbedingt in SQL drin haben.
Shell Exec, ja, ganz tolle Idee.
Ja, was könnte nur schief gehen?
But like Stack Overflow Guy in the FBI recommends, probably don't use it.
Move this complexity.
Move this logic to the application layer, if possible.
Command Shell isn't a free pass for hackers to instantly blow up your server, though.
It is only available...
Okay, Chat, lass mal kurz gucken.
Enzifog, so, was schreibt er denn?
Hi zusammen.
Ich hab kurz ne Frage an die ITler.
Wenn ich Windows 10 und Windows 11 Maschine klone, bleibt ja immer dieselbe SID bei...
Oh, Windows fragen.
Monk HS.
Da bin ich, bin ich sicher, ob wir dir hier so viel helfen können bei...
Okay.
Bleibt ja immer dieselbe SID beim User.
Jetzt habe ich einerseits gehört, dass es zu Problemen kommen kann und von andererseits keine Probleme macht.
Wie ist da deine allgemeine Meinung?
Kannst du nicht die SID einfach resetten?
Ich hab keine Ahnung von Windows, aber kann man die nicht einfach resetten?
Ich habe keinen plastischen Schimmer davon.
Vielleicht, vielleicht...
Wir haben manche Windows-Admins im Chat.
Ich hab hier ab und zu schon Windows-Fans gesehen.
Ob die jetzt gerade da sind?
Niemand will sich outen.
Ja, verständlich, verständlich.
Sollte kein Problem verursachen, sagt einer.
Ja, gut.
Also, du musst jetzt dem Chat glauben oder nicht, weil ich hab keine Ahnung.
Warte mal, ich hab...
Wait a moment, wait a moment.
Klingt sinnvoll, dass Shell ausführen nur Server-Admins dürfen oder System-Administranten.
Ja, wahrscheinlich lassen die ihren Server auch als System laufen und dann ist es eh vorbei.
Ja.
Das betrifft z.B. das Einstellen einer Rückentür, sodass sie in und auskommen können,
auch wenn die Vordertür gepatcht wird.
Aber das ist alles in der Firma's Corporate Network.
Per Payment Card Industry Data Security Standards, muss Heartland's Payment Processing System,
das Customer Credit Card Transactions handelt, in einer separaten Netzwerk.
Glücklicherweise haben die Hackers alle Zeit im Weltraum, um sich umzuschauen,
sich mit dem Stack kennenzulernen und das Onboarding-Dokumentation zu lesen.
By now, Heartland noticed a breach of the corporate network.
Maybe they saw something suspicious in the logs or some weird files.
Failing to find any leads to what the hackers were up to,
they hired Trustwave, a computer security firm, to conduct an audit.
They were deemed compliant with the aforementioned PCI Data Security Standards
and everyone went back to business after that.
Wait a minute!
Da haben die aber auf mehreren Ebenen verkackt, oder?
Ich mein...
Erstens haben sie es mit ihrer Datenbank schon komplett verschissen.
Dann haben die festgestellt, irgendwelche unerlaubten Aktivitäten,
haben sich irgendein Konsulten-Dienstleister reingeholt dafür
und der hat sich das angeguckt und hat gesagt, nee, passt alles,
alles entspricht den Regularien, weiter geht's.
Also das ist ja schon an mehreren Stellen verschissen.
As usual, both Heartland and the hackers, the latter of which having chilled
in the system for a bit over four months at this point.
Vier Monate? Ha!
Sometime in May, the hackers were able to make the jump to the Payment Processing Network.
How did they do that?
Heartland manages objects in their network, such as users, servers, network devices,
with Microsoft Active Directory.
Active Directory groups these objects into organizational units.
These organizational units are then grouped into domains,
these domains are grouped into trees,
and these trees are grouped into foursets.
At least according to this illustration I found online.
Anyways, just like real life, this is a hierarchical organization
where most users only have access to the stuff at their low levels.
But there are inevitably going to be a few privileged users of the highest level
that can access pretty much everything.
Let's say the hackers landed around here.
This would be the user which launched SQL Server.
You can probably see where this is going.
In order to verify the identity of users,
Heartland used an authentication protocol called NTOM,
or NT Land Manager.
Das klingt alt.
This provides single sign-on,
allowing a client to connect to various services using the same password.
Claude, bist das erste Mal hier auf Twitch? Nice!
Dann direkt bei mir, Pogu.
So muss das sein. Ich bin aber leider nicht mal lange on.
Wir gucken jetzt noch das eine Video fertig,
und dann bin ich wahrscheinlich schon wieder off.
Aber schön, dass du da bist.
Meddler!
Ach, tu ich gerade das Thema Meddler.
Meddler, Metal.
Wisst ihr, wo ich mich richtig drauf freue?
Am 2. Juni kommt das neue Glory Hammer Album.
Ja.
Da freue ich mich schon richtig drauf.
Die haben zwar den Sänger gewechselt,
aber ich habe mir die zwei Auskopplungen aus dem neuen Album schon mal angehört.
Ich muss sagen, das wird richtiger Banger, das Ding.
Zumindest wenn die anderen Songs ähnlich gut sind wie die zweite, die es schon gibt.
Ja, da freue ich mich drauf.
Alter.
Ich fand die drei vergangenen Alben auch schon top.
Okay, gucken wir mal weiter.
Was sagst du zu unserem ESC-Song?
Ist das Power Metal?
Ja.
Also Power Metal, nix da.
Power Metal.
Und absichtlich so cheesy Texte, dass es schon weh tut.
Aber ja, also mehr Power Metal geht nicht.
Ich meine, du musst dir ja mal allein die Titel angucken, ja?
Glory Hammer.
Release Date.
Tracklist.
Du musst dir allein schon mal die Titel angucken.
Hier.
Ich meine, alleine schon?
Alleine, wenn du so einen Songtitel liest.
Da weißt du, dass das Power Metal ist, oder?
Holy Flaming Hammer of Unholy Cosmic Frost.
Alles klar, oder?
Da weißt du schon, das muss Power Metal sein.
Und auch noch total übertrieben dazu.
Ja, also was sagst du zu unserem ESC-Song?
Ich fand den tatsächlich ganz okay.
Ist jetzt nix, was mich in höchste Verzögerung versetzt hätte als Metal-Fan.
Aber okay.
Also ehrlich gesagt, nix, was ich jetzt so im Stream rauf und runter gehört hätte so nebenbei.
Oder, ja, aber ehrlich gesagt, von vielem anderen dort fand ich das noch mit am besten.
Aber gut, dass wir da keine Punkte gekriegt haben, also erstens juckt's mich nicht.
Und zweitens wundert's mich auch nicht, weil wir kriegen ja eh meistens keine Punkte.
Und die, die Punkte kriegen, also dort, wenn ich irgendwann mal da reingucke, ist nicht unbedingt so sehr, weil der Song mega geil ist.
Sondern eher so, ah, okay, Moment, das ist aus Schweden, das heißt, der kriegt aus Dänemark, äh, Norwegen, Finnland schon mal alle Punkte und sonst noch was dabei.
Ja.
Aber ansonsten, ganz ehrlich, juckt mich überhaupt nicht.
Ich fand den Song tatsächlich ganz gut.
Es juckt mich aber, wie gesagt, überhaupt gar nicht, ob wir der Erste oder Letzte sind.
Also ich kann mich, ich kann mich, lass mal überlegen, an was kann ich mich beim ESC-Song noch erinnern?
Ich kann mich noch erinnern, dass wir mal Gildo Horn hatten.
Gildo hat euch lieb, Gildo Horn hatten wir mal, da kann ich mich noch dran erinnern.
Aber auch nur, weil's so bescheuert ist.
Dann hatten wir, äh, Stefan Raab.
Wadde hadde dude da.
Oder was in der Richtung.
Hatten wir mal.
Kann ich mich auch noch dran erinnern.
Ähm, äh, hatten wir denn sonst noch?
Ja gut, an Lordi kann ich mich natürlich noch erinnern, aber das war ja nicht von uns.
Es waren, glaub ich, äh, Lena gab's noch.
Da war, glaub ich, Finn oder so.
Lena, ja, genau, die gab's, die gab's auch noch.
Aber ansonsten, ich hab ernsthaft kein, es ist doch irgendein Max hatten wir da mal hingeschickt.
Vom Namen her kann ich mich da noch dran erinnern.
Irgendeinen Max hatten wir mal beim ESC von uns.
Ich glaub, ich glaub, ich glaub, der war auch mit und von Stefan Raab da irgendwie.
Ja genau, genau.
So, aber ansonsten, keine Ahnung.
Also, und auch keine Ahnung von den anderen Ländern, weil ich guck das nicht.
Ich hab das letzte Mal auch nicht geguckt.
Die letzten Jahre über nicht und das interessiert mich auch überhaupt nicht.
Also, Lordi hab ich mitgekriegt damals, das war eigentlich, das war aber auch wirklich guter Song.
Und auch gute Show.
Und auch durchaus was, was ich mir so hätte anhören können.
Aber die restlichen Sachen, pff, nö.
Ja schon, ne.
Amy Lee war bestimmt nicht beim ESC.
Die Band kenne ich und dass die beim ESC war, wusste ich nicht.
Ja, wir gucken jetzt mal das Video fertig.
Also, ich warte mal.
...
Just, I
Welcome
gefühlt haben 50% dieser Songs
Hammer im Namen
auch, ja. Aber
also was ich dir echt empfehlen
kann,
ähm,
das Album hier, das ist das zweite von denen.
Also sowohl
den Song als auch das Album,
das ist mega nice.
Das ist eines der, aus meiner Sicht
eines der besten Power-Metal-Alben so der
letzten Jahre.
Fast jeder Song hier,
absoluter Banger.
So, jetzt guck mal wirklich das Video fertig, sonst
wird das heute nichts mehr. Auf der
Hashcat-Seite sieht es nicht gut für NTLM aus.
Ja, hab ich auch im Hinterkopf.
Ja.
Using their newfound highly privileged
status, they were likely able to hop through
an unknown number of hosts to
eventually reach their destination.
Once within the payment network,
they booted up their packet-sniffing software
and began capturing in-flight
packets, which flowed across the network.
They discovered that the packets
contained unencrypted card numbers,
expiration dates, as well as the magnetic
strip information.
Another five months later,
Visa notified Heartland about...
Was ich da wieder sehr beeindruckend finde, ist, wie
langsam das alles ist.
Und das, obwohl sie es eigentlich
schon mal gemerkt haben. Ich meine, die können
nicht einfach alles so stehen lassen. Du musst davon
ausgehen, wenn du einmal einen Service
hattest, der kompromittiert war,
dann musst du eigentlich davon ausgehen, dass zumindest alles
da in dieser Umgebung
auch kompromittiert ist. Du kannst dich einfach
weiterlaufen lassen. Oh ja,
macht nix, weiter geht's.
Aber gut, wer Microsoft SQL
Server benutzt, hat wahrscheinlich eh die Kontrolle
da über sein Leben verloren.
Suspicious activities surrounding
certain cardholder accounts.
Heartland engaged forensic auditors
to investigate, and it would not be until
months later that the packet-sniffing
would be discovered.
Warum sind diese ganzen
Security-Consultants auch noch alle so lahm?
At the beginning of the new year,
the forensic team found the
hacker tools throughout Heartland's
servers and had a clear picture now
of the root cause, promptly shutting
down the attack as well as patching
any vulnerabilities.
On Inauguration Day, Heartland announces
that they have made a severe and
continuous lapse in judgment.
We have found evidence of an
intrusion last week, and
immediately.
Last week?
Die waren ja seit Monaten schon am Start,
man.
Kannst du ein Video posten?
Ja, kann ich machen.
Das ist auch immer so ein Ding,
ja? Wenn die dann
einfach nicht sagen können, was Sache ist,
sondern immer so,
ach, wir haben da einen Sicherheitsvorwand,
aber es ist eigentlich gar nicht so schlimm
und auch gar nicht so lang, und es ist eigentlich auch
gar nichts passiert, und dann kommt einfach
über die nächsten paar Monate raus,
dass immer mehr und immer schlimmer
und so, obwohl sie es wissen.
Notified law enforcement
officials as well as the card brands.
Also immediately the stock
plunged 40% in a single day,
dropping nearly 80%
at its lowest. Over a hundred
million credit and debit cards had
been compromised. That's like one
out of three Americans impacted, assuming
every card was American, that Americans own one credit card
on average, and that credit card ownership is evenly distributed.
But who was behind all of this?
The hack was carried out by Albert Gonzalez,
Vladimir Drinkman, Dmitry Smiljanets,
Alexander Kalinin, and probably a lot more people.
The same group of people
were involved in breaches of a bunch of companies,
Heartland being the most significant.
So we don't really know
who was involved in what breach.
As for the two Russians eventually
extradited to the US, Drinkman
was recently released in 2022,
and Smiljanets currently works
for a cyber security company.
Kalinin was never caught and is on
the Secret Services'
most wanted list. Gonzalez
is still in prison, scheduled for release
later this year.
Here are the recommendations published
by the FBI.
Number one, turn off XP
command shell. Disabling it is fine,
but given that you need to be sysadmin to use
it, sysadmin can also just enable
it again and use it anyways.
But you can also just delete the underlying
DLL file entirely.
Lower the max request length.
Microsoft's web server software will process
but not log requests over 4K.
Okay, schon mal zwei blöde Ideen.
Microsoft SQL und dann als
Application Server auch noch IES.
Ja, dann ist ja eh alles verloren.
It's long. So attackers can simply
just make their requests really long
with a certain bit of logs.
Three is just typical SQL injection
input validation. Four and five
are on least privilege. Every application
should only have permissions
required for its function.
No need to give the random web portal admin
power. If it gets compromised,
everyone else is in trouble.
Six and seven, use passwords.
Eight. Wie jetzt?
Eins, zwei, drei, vier, fünf, sechs ist aber auch
ein Passwort.
The minimal required software.
Perhaps the hackers utilized a Microsoft
Office exploit to hack into the mainframe.
Nine, ten and eleven deny access to the Internet.
Anyone who's worked with servers open to the
public Internet will have experienced tons of
random brute force SSH attempts.
Pretty typical stuff in the age of botnets.
More comprehensive logging, network monitoring.
Ja.
Und Datadog-Preise bezahlen.
Good luck, have fun.
Systematic reviews of set logs and metrics
could have also nipped it in the bud.
As well as encrypting all sensitive data
from end to end rather than just at rest.
The maximum timeline in which a company
can pretend a data breach never happened
is also much stricter nowadays.
At 30 days.
In the end, Heartland was fined
140 million dollars, though with
an estimated over 300 million
in losses to all involved.
On the bright side, they beat the data breach.
They beefed up their system and never got hacked again.
Unless you count the time in 2015,
when thieves broke into their offices
and stole a bunch of computers.
I guess you're only as secure as your weakest link.
Ist Grafana billiger?
Grafana kostet, wenn du es selbst hostet, gar nix.
Aber, sag mal so, gar nix kann man ja nie sagen.
Ja, stimmt ja nicht.
Du musst ja die Infrastruktur, das Administrieren und so.
Ja, aber Datadog ist berühmt-berüchtigt dafür,
dass sie ziemlich krasse, ähm,
Pricings haben für, äh,
ihren Service.
Monark S. Radiant Tracer, dankeschön.
Pock. Sup.
Danke, danke.
Du hattest eine Idee für den VM-Champ Bash Completion,
aber die ist broken.
Das ist schlecht. Da können wir sie wohl
nicht einbauen. Wir haben zwei Möglichkeiten.
Erstens, ich bin zu doof für
Bash-Magic. Oder zweitens,
wir müssen im Programm das, äh,
wahrscheinlich beides?
Ja, also wir müssen auf jeden Fall noch
nen Minus Minus Bash
oder Completion Bash oder so.
Anpassen. Das gibt's ja,
das gibt's ja, äh, noch nicht. Also,
ähm,
warte mal, ich mach das mal
ganz kurz auf.
Ne, hab ich nicht.
Also, das ist ja hier in, äh, äh,
im Main. Ja.
Guck mal, if complete gleich gleich
ZSH. Da gibt es schlicht und ergreifend
keine Abfrage für if complete
gleich gleich Bash.
Also, wenn wir Bash einbauen wollen, das muss da
auf jeden Fall noch als extra, äh,
äh, Branch als extra if, äh,
Zweig mit rein.
Ja. Else if
Bash. Sonst wird das
nicht funktionieren.
Auch cringe, dass überhaupt jemand Bash verwendet
dafür noch. Ich, ich
reboote mal kurz.
Wird.
Ah ja, das müssen wir auch noch machen. Okay, nice.
Gib ihm. Ich mach mal kurz
Updates, sonst muss ich das das nächste Mal wieder machen.
Okay.
Reboot. Warten, bis
der fertig ist. Chat gibt's
sonst noch irgendwas? Ich bin noch 10 Minuten on. Irgendwelche,
irgendwelche super mega wichtigen Sachen,
wo wir drüber reden müssen.
Ansonsten war's das nämlich von
meiner Seite aus für heut.
Mir fällt nämlich nichts mehr ein.
War nicht im Scope.
Genau.
Bash completion sollte
nie im Scope sein.
Gute Empfehlung.
AI Dilemma.
Donnerstag frei. Ja, sehr.
Habt ihr das Tim Leu... Nein, nein,
haben wir nicht, aber ich hab's, ich hab's, ich hab's, glaube
ich, aufgemacht für
future, future,
future gucken.
Irgendwo hier.
Ich weiß nicht, wo ich's aufgemacht
hab.
Irgendwo.
Kann man noch gucken? Okay.
Wo hab ich denn das Video aufgemacht?
Das Video von ihm hier.
Das da, ja.
Darum sollte nicht jeder programmieren.
Ja, gut.
Sollte
die meisten wollen ja auch gar nicht.
Nee.
Kommt nicht in Frage.
So, erste Mal, erste Mal Package
updaten. So, und
jetzt, den Packages
geupdatet sind. Mal gucken, ob Packages auch wirklich
geupdatet sind.
Excellent, excellent.
Und jetzt reboot.
Guck mal, der Pepo schläft schon. Habt ihr das
gesehen?
Das Hintergrund, das Hintergrund, das automatische
Hintergrundsetzen funktioniert.
Achtung.
Gleich ist der Pepo wieder am Start.
Da ist er.
Boomer müde.
Boomer schlafen.
Also ich muss sagen, die Hintergründe
hat er doch echt gut gemacht, der Rackman, oder?
Sind schon
äußerst, äußerst pog.
Kriege, ja.
Okay, dann lass uns das mal kurz angucken.
Das mittlere Jahresgehalt
von Softwareentwicklern in Deutschland
liegt laut Statistischem Bundesamt
bei knapp 69.000 Euro.
Das ist ja mal ordentliches Meme-Gehalt.
Ja, das ist ja mal ordentliches Meme-Gehalt.
...Architekten oder auch
Ingenieuren. Offensichtlich lohnt es sich
also monetär. Aber wieso sollte dann nicht jeder
Softwareentwickler werden? Moin Leute, ich bin
Tim, selbst Softwareentwickler.
Weil die meisten überhaupt keinen Bock da drauf haben, würde ich jetzt
einfach mal sagen. Und wahrscheinlich
auch, weil auch viele kein gutes
Händchen dafür haben. Aber oftmals
auch diese Leute schon dann gar keinen Bock haben.
Aber klar, natürlich
wie überall,
gibt auch sehr viele Unfähige.
...Softwareentwickler. Und genau
das will ich dir in diesem Video hier erklären.
Und zum Schluss gehe ich auch noch kurz darauf ein,
wer denn dann überhaupt programmieren lernen sollte.
Klar ist also, in der Informatik liegt
eine Menge Geld. Und das weiß auch der
Staat. Mehr Softwareentwickler heißt
dementsprechend auch mehr Steuereinnahmen.
Und wieso sollte man sich von ausländischen IT-Firmen
abhängig machen, wenn man die auch im eigenen Land haben kann?
Mittlerweile erreicht die Informatik
fast zu einem Standard.
Weil wir es ja nicht gebacken bekommen, aber es stellt schon
was dran.
...lesen und schreiben lernen. Denn die ersten Bundesländer
die führen Informatik als verpflichtendes
Schulfach ein. Und auch wenn ich
2023 wohlgemerkt,
ja, das ist halt alles Neuland.
...grundsätzlich dafür bin, dass
grundlegende Computer- und Informatikkenntnisse
wirklich sehr, sehr hilfreich sein
können, sollte und darf nicht
jeder programmieren lernen. Klar, jeder
darf und kann alles lernen. Aber wer
letztendlich alles kann, der kann eigentlich auch
gar nicht so richtig. Unsere Gesellschaft,
die hat es auch nur dank Spezialisierung soweit
geschafft. Und Programmieren ist halt eine davon.
Fangen wir jetzt einfach alle an zu programmieren,
für das sind sicherlich...
Naja, gut. Ey, Moment, Moment. Es geht ja in der
Schule nicht darum, selbst wenn man sowas in der
Schule macht, was ich bezweifle, selbst wenn
Informatik auf dem, äh, im
Kurs steht, weil die meisten Lehrer dazu überhaupt nicht
in der Lage sind. Da werden irgendwelche Word-Dokumente
erstellt oder sowas. Aber
das heißt ja nicht, dass sie später hauptberufliche
Softwareentwickler werden, sondern, dass man
in der Schule vielleicht damit schon in Kontakt kommt,
dass man eventuell feststellt,
ja, das, das
könnte was für mich sein.
Aber nicht unbedingt
dass die jetzt später automatisch
ähm,
Go-Geschichten entwickeln, oder?
Ist das? Ne.
Ne, JavaScript. Nicht
Go.
Block.json. Jaja, muss, muss JavaScript sein.
Kam ich jetzt drauf, dass
das Go ist? Sieht überhaupt nicht aus wie Go.
Zu keinem guten Ergebnis.
Das verschwendet letztendlich nur wertvolle Zeit und Ressourcen.
Aber welche Fähigkeiten musst du denn jetzt
eigentlich mitbringen, um Softwareentwickler oder
Programmierer zu werden? Die nächsten drei,
die solltest du definitiv haben. Bei der Softwareentwicklung
geht's darum, Probleme zu lösen.
Gut, das musst du auch bei echt vielen anderen berufen.
Aber bei der Softwareentwicklung kommt noch
hinzu, dass du nicht nur die
Programmiersprache, Computer oder Algorithmen
verstehen musst. Nein, du solltest auch das
anwenden. Ja, dazu muss man einfach Algorithmen
verstehen abonnieren und gut ist.
... in dem du das ganze brauchst verstehen.
Von der Entwicklung von Apps für Containerlogistik,
über die Digitalisierung
von irgendwelchen Prozessen für die Ticketkontrolle,
oder auch einfach nur Datenanalyse
für die strategische Ausrichtung eines Unternehmens.
Du musst also Spaß mitberufen.
Immer wieder etwas Neues zu lernen
und auch... Ja, aber das musst du nicht verstehen,
wenn du damit anfängst.
Also...
Wahrscheinlich verstehen das die meisten
professionellen Softwareentwickler nicht mal.
... Spaß mitbringen,
etwas Neues zu lernen, außerhalb
der Programmierwelt. Kurz gesagt,
du musst neugierig sein. Mit dieser
Neugier... Ja, das stimmt, da gebe ich ihm recht.
... geht dann also echt ein langer Prozess
einher. Du wirst dich am Anfang immer wieder dumm
fühlen, du fängst immer wieder von Punkt
Null an und initial verstehst du erst,
mal gar nichts. Es wird also relativ
lange dauern, bis du wirklich gute
Software schreiben kannst. Und ich muss
persönlich sagen, dass ich selbst auch...
Ich kann das auch nicht. Ich werde das auch nie können.
So wie die meisten auf dieser Welt.
Selbst professionelle Anwendungsentwickler.
... auch noch lange nicht an diesem Punkt
angekommen bin. Aber ich lerne weiter,
gebe nicht auf und ziehe einfach durch.
Die Fähigkeit, die du jetzt also mitbringen musst...
Aber eins muss man sagen,
es hilft,
wenn man sich ein bisschen mit Programmieren
beschäftigt. Also auch für Leute,
aus der Technik, die sonst mit Softwareentwicklung
nicht viel zu tun haben. Vielleicht eher
im administrativen Bereich tätig sind.
Aber auch, wenn man Interesse
daran hat und vielleicht mal irgendwann später
tatsächlich auch professioneller Softwareentwickler
werden will. Also...
Grundlagen in einer Sprache
helfen einem selbstverständlich auch beim Lernen
von anderen Sprachen.
... Durchhaltevermögen.
Durchhaltevermögen, dich nicht entmutigen
zu lassen, wenn es mal ein bisschen länger dauert, die neuen
Anwendungsfälle zu verstehen oder auch neue Prozesse
zu lernen. Ja, okay, das stimmt.
Das kann manchmal echt demotivierend sein.
Zu guter Letzt kann es sein, dass dir die Neugierde
und das Durchhaltevermögen auch überhaupt nichts bringen,
wenn du nicht diese eine letzte Fähigkeit
noch mitbringst. Denn Probleme lösen
ist nicht einfach. Und es gibt auch nicht
diesen einen Prozess, mit dem du jedes Problem
lösen kannst. Noch Twitch-Chat
Fragen. Die wissen das alles.
Du musst also immer...
Der Twitch-Chat kann sogar CSS
Sachen richtig stylen. Das
sollte eigentlich Beweis genug sein.
... wieder neue Wege finden und andere
Wege finden, um das Denken, um Herausforderungen
meistern zu können. Aber so ganz ohne Systematik
funktioniert das auch nicht. Ja.
Denn dann wirst du dich sehr schnell überfordert fühlen.
Heißt also, bring die richtige Mischung
aus abstraktem und logischem Denken mit.
Also aus Kreativität und
Systematik. Vielleicht denkst du jetzt auch einfach,
dass du zu dumm bist, um programmieren zu lernen.
Wieso das so ist und wie du das umgehen
kannst, das zeige ich dir jetzt. Ja,
gut. Ich meine, das war jetzt sehr allgemein
gehalten alles.
Das ist das beste Essen in Berlin.
Moment.
Kommt's bei ihm auch drauf an, ob das ein...
Ist das... Das muss schon eine Designer-Pizza sein, oder?
Also einfach nur...
Einfach nur Pizza geht da nicht.
Zumindest
hat die Pizza abgerundete Ecken. Das ist
sicherlich, sicherlich gut.
Von welchem großen Magenta-Provider
hast du deine Ausbildung gemacht?
Das würde voraussetzen, dass ich überhaupt
bei einem großen Provider
noch bei einem... Also und
bei einem großen Provider mit
Magenta eine Ausbildung
gemacht hab.
Vielleicht hab ich das ja auch.
Vielleicht doch nicht.
Ja, das stimmt.
Also wegen des Geldes,
wüsste ich jetzt nicht.
Aber man... Also ob sie das deswegen
machen, keine Ahnung. Aber man merkt
auf jeden Fall, wer einen gewissen
Bezug und
Denkweise hat, um was auf die Reihe
zu kriegen. Ja, das stimmt schon.
Das merkt man bei Azubis
finde ich auch recht schnell.
Du hast welche, von denen weiß ich, okay,
die kriegen das auf jeden Fall
auf die Reihe und welche, wo ich mir denke so,
ah, ob das was wird. Und meistens
muss ich sagen, liege ich da mit den Einschätzungen
oder lag ich bisher mit den Einschätzungen auch richtig.
Ganz selten wird man mal überrascht,
dass man sich denkt, ah,
bei dem bin ich mir nicht so sicher und
oder bei dem denke ich, wird das eher nix.
Beim Bestehen tun sie die Ausbildung alle,
aber großartig Ahnung haben,
danach ist wieder was anderes.
Aber manchmal wird man tatsächlich, selten wird man auch überrascht,
dass man sich denkt, oh ne, der kriegt das ja gar nicht
in den Backen und nach eineinhalb, zwei Jahren
kriegt er dann doch was gut auf die Reihe.
Das kommt aber selten vor.
Okay, Chatgis.
Ja, so Tests
oder so Übungssprachen,
Übungssachen gibt es ja jede Menge.
Da gibt es diese Sachen mit den Ameisen
und diesen
Roboter, der irgendwie
Labyrinthe ablaufen muss
und sowas. Gibt ja schon so ein paar
Einsteiger-Übungssachen,
aber das ist gar nicht verkehrt. Oder auch
Lego-Roboter.
Diese Lego, wie, ich weiß gar nicht, wie das hieß,
diese Lego-Geschichte, wo du
mit Microcontroller und so.
Das ist gar nicht so blöd,
wie sich das vielleicht anhört.
Da lernt man viel
dabei. Mindstorm, genau,
ja. Bad Practices,
Passwörter wie 123456
nehmen, zum Beispiel.
Obwohl ich das selbst mache.
Also, für so Sachen wie hier lokale
VMs und sowas, ne. Ihr müsst
gar nicht probieren, wenn ich mal irgendwelche
IPs bei Hetzner-Servern leake oder so,
euch da mit 123456 zu
connecten. Das wird nicht funktionieren.
Wahrscheinlich habe ich da sogar Passwort-
Authentifizierung aus. Tja, vielleicht
hast du ja auch recht. Vielleicht,
aber auch nicht. Ich werde es euch nicht sagen, wo ich
meine Ausbildung gemacht habe.
Was?
Ja!
Das lag aber nicht an mir, sondern an dem
Setup von dem Typ.
Das war schon, da habe ich blöd geguckt,
wo es den Fehler auf einmal gab und dann
stand Chewbaited in der Datei drin.
Ne, so einfach sind die Passwörter
auch nicht. Also, wenn ich Passwörter
verwende, dann mache ich die entweder mit
pwgen oder sowas.
Oder aus dem, oder mit dem
mit dem Passwort-Save.
Oder aber ich lasse
Passwort-Authentifizierung grundsätzlich aus.
Also, auf den meisten
Systemen ist das auch standardmäßig
gar nicht mehr eingeschaltet.
Passwort-Authentifizierung.
Da geht eh nur noch Key-Authentifizierung und
das ist auch die bessere Variante.
Okay, Leute. Ich gehe jetzt pennen.
Macht's gut. Bis denn. See you.